Notzäure, ich tue gerade meine Testaufnahme.
Ich lösche das aber wieder, aber es ist herrlich zu sagen.
Nicht löschen, nicht löschen.
Eigentlich würden wir die Aufnahme gerne selber haben.
Dann kriegt er es.
Nicht so laut.
Hi Kilian.
Hey Hendrik.
Wir sind heute in einer ganz anderen Situation.
Wir sitzen in einem echten Todstudio.
Boah krass, das ist so richtig retro.
Wie kam es denn dazu? Wir haben irgendwie
uns auf die Datenspuren begeben, diese
alljährlich stattfindende Mini-Kongress-Veranstaltung
vom C3D2, dem Chaos Computer Club Dresden.
So Mini ist das gar nicht. Wir bespaßen hier
Also Mini im Vergleich zum Kongress, meine ich.
Die bespaßen hier fünf Stockwerke in der technischen Sammlung
in Dresden und interessanterweise
steht hier auch ein
vollfunktion... ein fast vollfunktionsfähiges
Tonstudio.
Baujahr 1900 irgendwann zwischen
60 und 70.
Und es gibt hier ein paar
Enthusiasten, die sich schon seit gestern
Vormittag allein in diesem Tonstudio
aufhalten, die eigentlich auch Besucher der Datenspuren
sind und das hier wieder
funktionstüchtig machen und betreiben und uns
gerade aufnehmen. Das heißt, wir
sitzen gerade in den Datenspuren, in diesem
Tonstudio, nehmen das hier auf.
Wir haben da draußen eine Crew von
mal drei,
vier Leuten,
die diese Pegler bedienen und unsere
Aufnahme steuern. Vielen Dank
an dieser Stelle an euch. Ihr seid großartig.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
und wir hatten uns gedacht, wir hatten uns das schon vorher vorgenommen, eine Interview-Sondersendung zu machen.
Genau, wir wollten auf den Datenspuren unbedingt mal was anderes aufnehmen als unsere normale Laberkram-Sache
und mit ein paar Leuten reden, vor allem mit Speakern und die halt mit Interviewen quasi zu dem, was sie hier besprochen haben
und generell zu den Datenspuren ein bisschen plaudern.
Und dass wir das in diesem echten Tonstudio hier vor Ort machen können, ist natürlich noch ein Bonus, damit hatten wir gar nicht so richtig gerechnet.
Großer Zufall und ja, ein dickes fettes Plus.
Also diese Folge wird mittellang. Wir haben ein paar Leute interviewt, die hier Vorträge gehalten haben. Auf die können wir kurz eingehen. Wir haben interviewt.
Klar, zum ersten war es Anna Biseli, die bei Nespolitik arbeitet. Er kommt auch aus Dresden.
Genau, wir haben uns über ihren Vortrag über Videoüberwachung unterhalten. Dann haben wir uns unterhalten mit Axel Hübel, der hier einen Workshop zum Thema Crypto Keys, YubiKeys und so weiter gemacht hat und einen Vortrag gehalten hat über Paketmanager.
Genau. Dann haben wir uns mit
Medienpädagogikern unterhalten, genauer
mit Sandro, Nack und
Mandy, die hier einen tollen Stand betrieben
haben, wo sie Kinder Mindtest,
also ein freies Minecraft
Derivat haben spielen lassen und die
haben uns erklärt, was das mit Schule zu tun hat.
Genau, war super spannend
auf jeden Fall alles zusammen. Und dann habe ich noch ein spontanes
Interview mit ein paar Künstlern gemacht, die
hier eine Virtual Reality Ausstellung
gemacht haben. Da warst du gerade weg.
Ich bin gespannt.
Also, diesmal werden
dolle die Chapter Mark Funktionen
von eurem
Podcatcher missbrauchen müssen.
Also viel Spaß bei dieser
Interview Sonderfolge von den Datenspuren
2017. Nicht wundern übrigens,
wenn die Audioqualität ein bisschen schwankt
durch, sollte bedeutend besser sein zu jeder Zeit
als bei unseren normalen Aufnahmen, aber
wir haben unterschiedliche Mikro Setups benutzt
für die unterschiedlichen Interviews. Also es könnte sein,
dass es ein bisschen anders klingt. Genau. Gestern und heute
haben wir unterschiedliche Aufnahmen gemacht zu
unterschiedlichen Erforschungsgraden dieses
Studios. Und jetzt sitzen wir zum Beispiel
gerade mit den besten Mikros da. Das ist so
am Ende des Wochenendes.
Ein paar von den Interviews haben wir mit anderen Mikros aufgenommen.
Also vielleicht, mit ein bisschen Glück hört ihr den Unterschied
nicht, aber mal schauen.
Finde ich trotzdem fantastisch. Genau.
Genau. Viel Spaß beim Hören, würde ich sagen.
Jetzt geht's los.
Ist das drauf?
Ihr könnt gerne schon auf Rekord drücken, wenn ihr wollt.
Das ist ganz kurz.
So nah wie möglich an den Tisch ranruppen.
Und gerne leise, stimme halt in der Mitte.
Dann haben wir es doch ganz gut, oder?
Ja, das kriegen wir hin.
Wart man das? Ist das in Ordnung?
Also, wir sitzen jetzt hier mit Anna Biseli von Netzpolitik.org.
Hallo Anna.
Hallo.
Du bist eine der Rednerinnen hier bei den Datenspuren 2017
und hast einen Vortrag gehalten über Videoüberwachung.
Wie bist du zu dem Thema gekommen?
Na A, es ist so ein bisschen mein Job und ich beschäftige mich mit dem Thema halt irgendwie seit einer ganzen Weile journalistisch, das heißt eigentlich mit so ziemlich allen Überwachungsthemen, aber eben auch Videoüberwachung.
Und das Thema wird gerade so in den letzten Jahren immer wieder sehr hochgekocht, weil es einfach oftmals, wenn irgendwo was passiert, die Forderung ist, eben die Videoüberwachung auszuweiten und das Ganze beruht selten auf rationalen Argumenten.
Das heißt, du würdest sagen, je mehr Videoüberwachung, desto besser und sicherer wird die?
Ist ja voll nachweislich, dass das demnächst in der Fall ist.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, dass wir das eben nicht nachweisen können, dass das irgendwas bringt.
Das heißt, es wird erstmal so Videoüberwachung eingerichtet und Videoüberwachung ausgeweitet,
aber wir haben einfach keine verlässlichen Untersuchungen, ob das überhaupt was bringt.
Und es gibt da ganz interessant so eine Diskrepanz zwischen der Wahrnehmung,
ob Videoüberwachung was bringt und der Bereitschaft, mehr Videoüberwachung zu akzeptieren.
Und zwar ist ein Großteil der Bevölkerung tatsächlich eher befürwortend gegenüber Videoüberwachung eingestellt,
aber eben nur ein Teil davon denkt wirklich, dass es hilft, die Welt sicherer zu machen.
Und das ist ganz interessant, weil das erstmal so eine Maßnahme ist, die eben keine Sicherheit bringt,
sondern so eine gefühlte Sicherheit, weil eine Videokamera wird eben nicht verhindern,
dass jemand zum Beispiel eine Treppe runtergeschubst wird.
Ich meine, mehr Visioüberwachung kann man ja einfach mal machen, aber tut ja keinem weh.
Vielleicht bringt es was, vielleicht auch nicht.
Es tut ja keinem weh, das merkt keiner direkt, das heißt, es tut ja nicht direkt weh,
aber auf der anderen Seite verliere ich ja damit die Möglichkeit, mich unerkannt durch den öffentlichen Raum zu bewegen.
Und eigentlich, wenn ich darüber mal nachdenken würde, dass irgendwie jede Videokamera, die ich so in der Öffentlichkeit sehe,
wirklich aufzeichnet, was ich mache und ich nicht so richtig weiß, wo das gerade liegt, wo diese Daten liegen,
dann ist das ja eigentlich schon ein ziemlich krasser Eingriff in mein Recht auf Privatsphäre.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist so ein Hintergedanke, den ich neulich, war ich mal wieder in England, da ist ja echt alles überwacht.
Halschland dafür eindeutig.
Aber man hat irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie die Engländer da mitzuleben, die wissen ja
wirklich, dass sie jeden Moment, wo sie aus dem Haus kommen, die ganze Zeit in der Öffentlichkeit
gefilmt werden.
Da scheint das irgendwie ganz normal zu sein für die Leute oder gibt es da irgendwie, wisst
ihr, ob es da Bewegungen gibt, dass die Leute sagen, wir brauchen weniger CCTV, macht das
mal alles wieder aus?
Na klar, es gibt halt irgendwie so ziemlich in jedem Land Bewegungen, die sagen, wir sollen
zumindest Videoüberwachung nicht weiter ausweiten.
Da hört man auf, das so irrational zu machen.
Aber das dringt eben nicht bis zur,
es dringt schon bis zu den Politikern durch,
die das zu entscheiden haben oder zu den Polizeien,
die die Videoüberwachung einsetzen.
Aber das ändert halt leider gerade noch nichts,
weil es keine rationale Diskussion darüber gibt.
Auch wenn immer wieder gefordert wird,
so macht doch mal Untersuchungen, was das bringt.
Auf diese Untersuchungen warten wir seit Ewigkeiten.
Und das, was es gibt, ist primär eine Sache von,
ja, seitdem gingen die Straftaten gefühlt zurück.
Oder dann gibt es wieder Untersuchungen, die ganz komisch sind, dass zum Beispiel Polizisten so Bodycams bei sich haben, das heißt Kameras am Körper, die dann eben aufnehmen sollen, was ihr gegenüber so tut.
Und dann gab es dann irgendwie eine Untersuchung aus Frankfurt, wo gesagt wurde, ja, seitdem ging die Kriminalität gegen Polizisten zurück.
Das fand ich cool in deinem Vortrag.
Aber das Problem war eben, dass im gleichen Atemzug die Streifengröße von irgendwie zwei Polizisten auf so drei, vier Polizisten erhöht haben.
Und natürlich überlege ich mir, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie vier Polizisten gegenüberstehe,
eher, ob ich jetzt gegen die Polizisten irgendwie angehe, als wenn da zwei Polizisten stehen.
Und dann ist es halt auch nicht aussagekräftig.
Und das ist eben das riesige Problem, dass wir keine Fakten haben.
Und du hattest irgendwie in deinem Vortrag die Zahlen,
dass die Angriffe auf Polizisten um 37 Prozent runtergegangen sind.
Und das waren aber in Zahlen, waren das von 27 pro Jahr auf 20 pro Jahr?
Genau, das heißt, es gibt einfach keine wirklich große Menge,
mit der man irgendwie eine Aussage über eine Signifikanz stellen könnte.
Gibt es eigentlich Möglichkeiten, diese Daten aktuell überhaupt auszuwerten in dem Maße, wie sie aufgenommen und gesammelt werden?
Oder wird es einfach nur zwischengespeichert, gelagert bis zu dem Fall, dass man mal drauf schauen möchte?
Eigentlich werden die Daten nach einer gewissen Zeit automatisch überschrieben.
Das heißt zum Beispiel bei Überwachung in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln hat man in Dresden,
werden die Daten nach 24 Stunden automatisch überschrieben oder in Berlin sind es 48 Stunden.
Das habe ich schon erlebt, ich habe die DVB mal angeschrieben, weil ich einen lustigen Zwischenfall auf Video haben wollte.
Die haben es leider nicht mehr, aber ich dürfte dem eh nicht ergeben.
Das gibt es glaube ich in England, da kannst du irgendwie, das hat der Linus Neumann mal in einem LNP erzählt, der hatte einen Fahrradunfall und konnte dann irgendwo dann sich von der Kreuzung, wo das passiert ist, konnte sich die Videoaufzeichnung geben lassen.
Ja, das kann eben normalerweise die Polizei machen, aber da müssen sie halt auch innerhalb dieser Zeit dann irgendwie ankommen und diese Daten haben wollen.
Was ja normalerweise funktioniert, weil ja 48 Stunden später die Sache eigentlich schon gelaufen sein sollte und dann jemand eine Anzeige gestellt haben sollte.
Aber das Problem ist, wenn wir das gerade nicht so bei Verkehrsbetrieben haben, wo das relativ in geregelten Bahnen abläuft,
sondern von aus ist jetzt Wiederüberwachung im nächsten Kiosk oder im Supermarkt,
da wird sehr, sehr selten kontrolliert, ob die Voraussetzungen überhaupt eingehalten werden.
Wir hatten das irgendwie vor der SPD-Zentrale in Berlin.
Da war eben die Speicherdauer zehn Tage und das ist deutlich unzulässig.
Das heißt eigentlich mehr als zwei, drei Tage speichern ist nicht mehr drin, weil das ist dann nicht mehr verhältnismäßig,
weil niemand begründen kann, dass man die Daten so lange braucht.
Weil wenn irgendwas passiert oder dir jemand die Scheibe einschlägt, merkst du das schneller als drei Tage später.
Und wenn irgendein Kioskbesitzer seine Kundschaft dauerhaft filmt und das für fünf Jahre speichert, merkt man das ja auch?
Nö, in der Regel merkst du das nicht.
Es sei denn, du gehst halt hin und sagst, hier, zeig mir mal bitte, wie lange du das speicherst.
Und dann kriegst du vielleicht eine Antwort und dann kann man mal gucken oder sich beim Datenschutzbeauftragten beschweren.
Dann kommt der und schreibt einen Brief und sagt, guck mal, wie lange du das speicherst.
Und dann sagt er, du, du, du, aber dann geht es halt irgendwie weiter.
Das ist auch das, was ich mache, wenn ich irgendwo eine Kamera sehe, wo ich der Meinung bin, dass die nicht berechtigt ist, dann sage ich da Bescheid, zu wem gehe ich hin, zur nächsten Tür, die da in der Nähe ist.
Ja, erstmal sollst du dich an den Betreiber selber wenden, das heißt, der formal richtige Weg wäre hinzugehen und zu sagen, hier, ich habe das Gefühl, deine Kamera, das ist nicht in Ordnung, zum Beispiel, die guckt auf den Gehweg oder so, das darfst du ja eigentlich auch nicht, das heißt, die darf normalerweise keinen öffentlichen Raum erfassen, sondern wenn, dann nur den Bereich vor einer Ladentür zum Beispiel.
Und dann kann man versuchen, darüber was zu erreichen. In der Regel wird dann eben nichts passieren wahrscheinlich. Und dann kann man sich an den zuständigen Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten wenden und sagen, hier, guck da mal bitte nach. Und dann passiert auch in der Regel was. Aber es kann eben lange dauern. Das heißt, die Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten sind ziemlich überlastet. Die verschleppen das nicht aus bösem Willen, sondern es dauert dann halt teilweise einfach ein halbes Jahr oder sogar noch länger, bis dann was passiert. Aber die gehen dem auf jeden Fall nach.
Gilt das auch für den Kioskbetreiber, von dem ich denke, dass er aus Versehen Gehweg mitfilmt?
Oder kann ich da irgendwie zur Polizei gehen oder zum Ordnungsamt?
Nö, da gehst du zum Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Die Polizei sagt, nö, ist ja sicher, ist ja in Ordnung.
Naja, die Polizei hat damit erstmal nicht viel zu tun.
Das ist ja ein rechtlicher Versturz.
Ja, du machst aber erstmal keine Anzeige, sondern höchstens, wenn der dann irgendwie sagt,
nee, will ich aber weitermachen, dann kannst du irgendwann eine Anzeige machen.
Also der normale Weg ist erstmal über den Datenschutzbeauftragten zu gehen.
Okay, aber jetzt gibt es ja, du hast in deinem Vortrag auch berichtet über diesen Testversuch, dieses Pilotprojekt am Berliner Bahnhof Südkreuz. Was für eine Grauzone muss man sich denn bewegen, damit man so einen öffentlichen Raum ganz einfach so filmen kann?
Ich darf einen Geweg nicht überwachen, aber so ein Bahnhofsterminal darf ich überwachen?
Ja, das macht ja die Deutsche Bahn in Verbindung mit der Bundespolizei. Das heißt, das Ding gehört ja der Bahn und dann darf die Bahn auch filmen und Überwachungskameras an Bahnhöfen gibt es ja schon eine ganze Weile. Das heißt, darf die Bahn machen. Bundespolizei macht bei diesem Pilotprojekt mit.
Aber eigentlich darf man noch keine Videoüberwachung mit Gesichtserkennung machen.
Das heißt, das, was sie da machen, nämlich die Gesichter der Leute aufzunehmen und zu versuchen, die mit einer Datenbank abzugleichen,
das geht noch nicht in Deutschland, da gibt es keine Gesetzesgrundlage für.
Und deswegen haben sie sich so einen Dreh ausgedacht, zu sagen, wir machen das basierend auf Einwilligung.
Das heißt, Leute, die an diesem Testversuch teilnehmen wollen, geben ein Bild von sich her, das wird in die Datenbank geschubst.
und dann versuchen sie eben gegen diese Bilder abzugleichen und die Gesichter der restlichen Passanten und Passagiere werden dann eben nicht gefunden
und sie können sich auf Wegen bewegen, ohne in diese intelligente Videoüberwachung rein zu geraten,
was dann aber auch dazu führt, dass wenn man die Rolltreppe nach unten nehmen will, dass man dann jetzt in Zukunft die Treppe laufen muss
oder sich in den Aufzug stecken muss, weil eben die Rolltreppe nach unten zum Beispiel nicht benutzbar ist, ohne durch diesen Bereich zu laufen.
Also das heißt, es ist genauso wie dieser anlasslose Verdacht.
Ich bin erstmal, selbst wenn ich nicht an diesem Versuch teilnehme, potenzieller Versuchsteilnehmer und werde angeguckt.
Und dann erst, wenn die erkennen, dass ich nicht in einer dieser Liste von 300 Freiwilligen, die ein iPhone gewinnen können, bin, dann werde ich erst rausgeschmissen.
Du wirst dann rausgeschmissen, aber die 300 Freiwilligen haben auch so einen kleinen RFID-Chip dabei, damit man eben gucken kann, ob das System richtig lag.
weil sonst ist es ja ein bisschen schwierig, weil sonst kannst du ja immer nur gucken, wenn das System jemanden findet,
aber um halt zu gucken, wen das System zum Beispiel nicht erkennt, haben die Leute so einen kleinen Schlüsselanhängermäßiges Ding dabei,
das dann oben an der Treppe zum Beispiel so einen Empfänger hat und guckt, wer ist denn da heute durchgelaufen.
Außerdem, die Spezialpreise kriegen natürlich nur die Leute, die da ganz oft durchlaufen.
Das heißt, jeder Teilnehmer, der eine bestimmte Anzahl an Passagen an diesem Gebiet bekommt, kriegt seinen Amazon-Einkaufsgutschein
und wer dann irgendwie am eifrigsten da durchgelaufen ist, der kriegt dann nochmal einen Spezialpreis.
Irgend so was wie eine Smartwatch.
Das Gamification für Überwachung.
Ja, das ist total gut.
Super.
Hast du mal, läuft dieses Pilotweite noch?
Ja, das läuft noch bis zum zweiten Quartal 2018.
Also es soll insgesamt so ein halbes Jahr ungefähr dauern.
Und ab Januar soll dann auch eine Verhaltenserkennung dazukommen.
Das heißt, bis jetzt wird eine Gesichtserkennung getestet, ob man die Leute wiedererkennt.
Und ab Januar wollen sie dann auch auffällige Situationen erkennen.
Und was genau heißt das?
Was beinhaltet sowas potenziell?
Wenn jemand an dem anderen rumzerrt.
Ist noch nicht ganz klar.
Es soll auf jeden Fall sowas sein, wie zum Beispiel jemand fällt irgendwie hin oder sowas.
Oder eigentlich auch sowas wie jemand fällt auf die Gleise.
Oder jemand wird quasi gewalttätig angegangen.
Oder man wurde aber auch schon, man hat sich so ein bisschen in die Richtung bewegt.
Naja, wenn jemand jetzt ein Graffiti an die Wand spult, können wir das auch super erkennen.
Dann können wir da was machen.
Das heißt, es geht dann nicht mehr um Straftaten gegen Leib und Leben.
und um ganz, ganz schlimme Dinge, sondern im Zweifelsfall
im Operativbetrieb dann auch darum, dass
irgendjemand was an die Wand schmiert und jemand
dann schneller gefunden werden kann. Prävention
bringt sowas ja sowieso in keinem Fall. Du kannst
ja bloß zuschauen, während jemand auf die Gleise fällt.
Was wir dann machen? Jemand schnell vorbeischicken, der nicht
da schon rumstehen könnte? So muss halt kein Sicherheitsbeamter mehr
auf die ganze Zeit auf die Kamera gucken und aufschreiben,
da ist jemand auf die Gleise gefallen, sondern das System lockt automatisch.
Der wird das loggen, ja.
Weißt du was, wir haben
immer mehr Fragen ein. Hast du mal mit
irgendjemandem von diesen Beteiligten gesprochen,
die da freiwillig daran teilnehmen?
Ja, so viel.
Habe ich das?
Nee, ich glaube tatsächlich nicht.
Das würde mich interessieren. Die sind dann bestimmt total
so unaware und sagen,
ja, ist cool oder so. Ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen.
Das würde mich mal interessieren, was so an den
Leuten vorgeht, die an sowas teilnehmen.
Dass vielleicht irgendwelche konservativen
Leute sind, die sagen, wir brauchen
mehr Videoüberwachung und deswegen mache ich damit.
Oder irgendwelche so ahnungslosen
Millennial-Kiddies, die sich
denken, Smartwatch ist cool und
Videoüberwachung habe ich eh schon überall.
Also das würde mich echt mal faszinieren.
Ja, tatsächlich ist ja die Akzeptanz von Videoüberwachung, sag ich mal so, in der Gesamtbevölkerung relativ hoch.
Das heißt, über die Hälfte der Leute, das war eine Umfrage in Berlin vor einem Jahr, glaube ich,
hat eine Ausweitung von Videoüberwachung eher positiv gesehen.
Das heißt, ich kann mir schon gut vorstellen, dass Leute dann sagen, naja, klar wollen wir das,
weil dann können die bösen Verbrecher und die bösen Terroristen einfacher gefasst werden,
weil dann wissen wir ja gleich irgendwie mit ihrem Gesicht, dann kriegen wir die einfacher.
Man müsste die Leute, glaube ich, fragen, okay, in der momentanen Situation,
würden sie mehr Videoüberwachung begutheißen?
Und dann müsste man, glaube ich, als Nachfolgefrage stellen,
was ist, wenn man im Moment schafft,
die technische Grundlage für potenziell nachfolgende Regierungen,
die nicht mehr so positiv drauf sind.
Wenn jetzt Donald Trump Präsident von Deutschland wäre,
würden sie dann mehr Videoüberwachung begutheißen?
Ich glaube, das ist eben auch so ein Problem,
dass Leute nicht so richtig sehen, was es für Folgen haben kann.
Ich meine, man muss nicht unbedingt großartig die Verschwörungstheorie aufmachen,
aber allein schon zu sehen, das wird dann eben nicht mehr dafür benutzt,
irgendwie oder nur dafür benutzt, den Verbrecher zu fangen, sondern Leute, die ein Graffiti
an die Wand sprayen und irgendwann hört es halt auch auf.
Also dann ist halt die Frage so, was ist jetzt noch konformes Verhalten und wo schlägt dann
der Alarm an?
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie orientierungslos am Bahnsteig hoch und runter laufe, weil ich
gerade nervös bin, weil ich irgendwie ein Bewerbungsgespräch habe, bin ich dann auffällig, weil ich könnte
ja auch irgendjemand sein, der eine Straftat plant und deshalb irgendwie nervös hoch und
runter läuft.
Das ist eben die Frage, wie Leute dann ihr Verhalten anpassen, wenn sie sich überlegen
müssen, was konform ist.
Und was konform ist, bestimmen ja nicht die Leute selbst, das bestimmen ja andere.
Ja, dann muss es bloß ein paar Mal passieren, dass du dann von der Polizei herausgezogen wirst, weil du dich komisch bewegt hast und schon achten die Leute, das ist ja was, was man im Hinterkopf immer automatisch macht, beobachte ich auch bei mir selber irgendwie, weil ich weiß, da und da, das liest jemand mit, wenn ich das und das jetzt auf Google suche, dann denken die das bestimmt das und das von mir, das beeinflusst schon das Verhalten der Menschen.
Verhalten musst du dann auf die Listen da kommst, dass du auf die No-Fly-Listen direkt kommst.
Weißt du, was da für Software eingesetzt wird?
Ja, es gibt für die Gesichtserkennungstests drei Hersteller, die ausgewählt wurden.
Aber ich glaube, ich weiß gerade die drei Hersteller nicht mehr.
Ich weiß zumindest, dass es in Dresden irgendwie auch eine Softwarefirma gibt, die sich auf Gesichtserkennung spezialisiert hat.
Ich glaube, eine Dresdner Firma war nicht dabei.
Es war, glaube ich, eine britische Firma und, glaube ich, Level 1 war dabei und noch eine andere.
Und eine andere aus Deutschland, die eigentlich bei fast allen Bundesprojekten dabei war, wurde nicht ausgewählt.
Ich glaube, Cooking Tech, aber es kann aber auch umgekehrt sein.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie drei verschiedene Softwares genommen, um die zu testen.
Und welche Software für die Verhaltenserkennung genutzt wird, steht noch gar nicht fest.
Achso.
Ja, durchaus spannend.
Also ich empfehle den Leuten, die das jetzt hier hören,
wenn ihr noch nicht auf den Datenspuren wart und Andras Vortrag noch nicht gehört habt,
dann schaut euch auf jeden Fall die Aufzeichnung von ihrem Vortrag auf datenspuren.de an,
die hoffentlich in den nächsten Tagen veröffentlicht werden.
Oder zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir es schaffen, unseren Podcast.
Im Wunder.
Von den nächsten Datenspuren.
Genau.
Ansonsten hast du, wir haben dich ja gerade überall gesucht, du hast gerade noch geprobt.
Wir können das ja wahrscheinlich hier ansprechen, weil wir eh nach dem Auftritt erst veröffentlicht werden.
Du hast noch ein zweites Projekt, mit dem du hier auf den Datenspuren antrittst.
Kannst du darüber ein bisschen was erzählen?
Ja, das haben wir letztes Jahr auf dem Chaos Communication Congress U aufgeführt.
Das ist eine Theaterverarbeitung des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses.
Das heißt, ich und mein Kollege, wir haben ja ziemlich oft oder eigentlich immer abwechselnd in diesem Ausschuss gesessen, um live mitzutippen,
als eben die Tätigkeiten von der NSA in Deutschland und die Tätigkeiten des BND zusammen mit der NSA untersucht werden sollten.
Da gab es ja erstmal keine Protokolle, keine öffentlichen, also haben wir gesagt, wir wollen das öffentlich zugänglich machen und haben uns halt diesen ganzen Kram reingezogen.
Das waren, glaube ich, über 600 Stunden insgesamt.
Also du sagst über 600 Stunden mit in dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss?
Ja, zusammen mit ihm, also so die Hälfte der Zeit ungefähr.
Und hast Hand mitgeschrieben oder mitgetippt?
Mitgetippt.
Aber du durftest irgendwie keine Tonwertaufnahmen machen und hast alles Steno so mitgeschrieben.
Ja, genau. Es macht einem ein bisschen matschig in der Birne.
Gute Freizeitbeschäftigung.
Dann wird irgendwann ziemlich komisch, vor allem wenn man dann irgendwann bis nachts um 12 sitzt.
Das ist auch passiert.
Und dann irgendwann kommt so das Bedürfnis, das zu verarbeiten.
Weil man weiß ja, okay, es gab immer noch so ein paar Menschen, die haben das dann gelesen.
Hat mich immer wieder beeindruckt.
Ich glaube, ich hätte das selber nicht gemacht.
Die haben sich wirklich diese Protokolle dann durchgelesen, die wir geschrieben haben.
Aber eigentlich will man das ja Leuten zugänglich machen, weil das ist ja schon, das grenzt ja schon an absurdes Theater, was da passiert ist, einfach mal diese Geheimdienstler, diese Deutschen zu sehen, wie die sich verhalten und wie sie halt versuchen, Erinnerungslücken vorzutäuschen oder wie sie sagen, ja, mein Dienstherr erlaubt mir nicht, das zu sagen und also diese ganze Palette an Ausreden und irgendwann will man das irgendwie der Welt irgendwie näher bringen und weiß natürlich irgendwie, da draußen liest keiner diese ganzen Protokolle.
Also haben wir uns überlegt, wir machen dann eine Theaterinszenierung oder eine Lesung draus und versuchen so die besten oder die charakteristischsten Szenen daraus zusammenzuschneiden und das dann so ein bisschen zu kondensieren, was darin vorgegangen ist. Das sind alles Originalaussagen, das heißt wir haben daran nichts verändert. Wir haben das natürlich hart zusammengekürzt und ausgesucht, aber das macht glaube ich ganz gut klar, wie abstrus diese Situation da ist.
Das ist jetzt die gleiche
Aufführung, die ihr schon auf dem Kongress letztens
hattet? Genau. Aber die ist nicht aufgezeichnet worden?
Doch, doch. Die müsste aufgezeichnet worden sein.
Ich glaube, die wird hier jetzt aber nochmal aufgezeichnet.
Trotzdem sehr unterhaltsam auf dem Kongress. Also die Aufzeichnung
kann ich wärmst uns empfehlen. Also die Aufzeichnung war,
ich saß mit ganz vorne
und es war auf jeden Fall sehr spannend
und sehr unterhaltsam. Das habt ihr
sehr cool gemacht, fand ich. Ja, abschreckend.
Es war aber auch wirklich,
das ging halt
in die Richtung Kabarett. Das war schon
wirklich gut gemacht. Ne, das sind reale
Aussagen von deutschen Beamten.
Das ist kein Kabarett, das ist nicht witzig.
Von den Aussagen
her, die da gemacht wurden, war es schon wirklich
echt zynisch
bis albern an vielen Stellen.
Ja, aber man durfte da nicht mal
Popcorn essen. Also das Wunder war ja, man saß da oben
auf diesem Besucherring mit diesen unglaublich
unbequemen Stühlen, mit diesen Klappstühlen, hatte
nach 13 Stunden irgendwie riesige Schmerzen
im Hintern und man durfte nicht mal Popcorn
essen. Also das war schon, also irgendwie muss man das
verarbeiten, dass das dann rausgekommen ist.
War dir da nicht manchmal, wenn du da drin saßt, ich weiß nicht, warst du da
ganze Zeit so beschäftigt mit Tippen, dass du nicht dazu gekommen bist oder hast du dir manchmal
eigentlich gedacht, ey, what the fuck, war dir manchmal danach irgendwie da reinzurufen und zu
sagen, sag mal, spinnt ihr oder sowas? Ja, man musste ab und zu lachen, das durfte man offiziell nicht.
Ja, vor allem haben die Leute da auch Humor, ist man auch für mal in der Gruppe in Gelächter ausgebrochen
bei manchen Dingen? Ja, sicher, sicher natürlich, aber offiziell darf man das nicht, weil Geh- und
Missfallensbekundungen von der Besuchertribüne sind im Deutschen Bundestag verboten. Das heißt,
nicht lachen, aber manchmal musste man trotzdem lachen.
Also manchmal mussten die Abgeordneten auch lachen.
Da kommt halt irgendwie so eine absurde Scheiße bei raus,
von wegen, ich erinnere mich nicht dran.
Aber sie haben das unterschrieben.
Ja, weil ich erinnere mich nicht dran,
also da kommt halt wirklich absurder Kram bei raus.
Da muss man halt lachen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn man da halt sitzt und das mittippt,
dann geht das auf der einen Seite rein,
kurz durch die Finger, auf der anderen Seite wieder raus.
Und das hat man auch ganz gut gemerkt,
weil wir haben meistens nach den Sitzungen
einen Podcast aufgenommen, direkt danach.
Und da kommt einem dann so stückchenweise wieder, was da eigentlich passiert ist.
Stimmt, dann wollte ich auch nochmal empfehlen, das ist technische Aufklärung, heißt der Podcast, oder?
Das finde ich auch ziemlich bemerkenswert.
Also ich muss an dieser Stelle, das habe ich dir glaube ich noch nicht gesagt,
Hochachtung für die Arbeit, die du da geleistet hast.
Vor allem, dass du dich hinterher noch, da habt ihr das aufgenommen auf den Stufen vom Bundestag?
Ja, je nach Wettersituation.
Manchmal innen drin, manchmal im Bundestag, manchmal auch woanders innen drin,
wenn es gar nicht mehr ging und nachts irgendwie sehr kalt draußen war.
aber oftmals direkt vor dem Bundestag.
Dass ihr euch da irgendwie stundenlang hingesetzt habt,
diese Schmieren-Komödie da mitgetippt habt
und dann hinterher auch noch genug Nerven
habt, das dann auch nochmal an ein Mikrofon zu sprechen.
Also wer von
den drei Zuhörern, die wir haben, das noch nicht kennt,
ich empfehle wärmstens den
Podcast Technische Aufklärung, wo Anna Bicilli
auch sehr häufig dabei war.
Und das
Stück, was ihr jetzt
nochmal darbietet,
erträgt welchen Titel?
Das heißt nicht öffentlich, wobei wir diesen Titel nie wieder
wählen werden, weil sehr viele Leute fragen,
ob man da jetzt hingehen darf oder nicht.
Das war auf dem Congress auch wirklich ein Running Gag.
Das war auf dem Congress wirklich ein Running Gag.
Das ist echt großartig, so ein Ding, das in Saal 1
wirklich so zur Primetime läuft, wo nicht öffentlich
drüberstehen, Leute fragen, ob man da hingehen darf.
Hat das überhaupt aufgenommen?
Wir haben diesen paar tausend Leute-Saal einfach nur für uns.
Also ja,
man darf das angucken, ich werde das nächste Mal
einen anderen Titel nehmen.
Das ist so ein bisschen, als ob man eine Band hat und die dann heute
geschlossen nennt. Teilnahme verboten.
Es gibt so eine Band aus Ingolstadt, die heißt Slut.
Die haben so schon Probleme mit ihrem Namen.
Das heißt, glaube ich, aber auf Schwedisch geschlossen.
Und wenn die auf Tour waren irgendwo im Norden,
dann sind teilweise die Leute auf 100 vor den Eingängen
da stehen geblieben, weil da geschlossen dran stand.
Das ist der Tee-Name.
Ja, cool. Vielen lieben Dank, Anna,
dass du ein paar Fragen von uns beantwortet hast.
Danke auch.
Wir wollen ja jetzt noch ein paar andere Leute auf den Datenspuren interviewen.
Wir könnten uns mit dir wahrscheinlich noch wesentlich länger unterhalten.
Aber um nicht redundant zu werden, du bist ja auch relativ häufig, aber du bist schon ein paar Mal bei Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Gast gewesen.
Ich glaube zweimal oder so, ja.
Und gibt es noch andere Podcasts, in denen man dich manchmal hört?
Nee, ich glaube, ich bin eher podcast-scheu.
Ja, potenziell nicht.
Aber ansonsten, also
schaut euch an, die sind nochmal bei Aufzeichnungen
vom Chorus Communication Kongress an
und von den Datenspuren.
Vielen lieben Dank, dass du die Zeit
einmal hast für uns.
Und damit kommen wir jetzt zum nächsten
Erdruck. Dankeschön.
Sehr schön. Nur mal als Tipp,
das Museum möchte gern, dass
dieses Studio regelmäßig genutzt wird.
Und ich glaube, die werden richtig
happy. Ey, das wäre doch was.
Du musst ja jedes Mal hier ein bisschen rausfahren.
Das ist ja jöt wie dir.
J-T-W-
noch einen vortrag aber der workshop heute war eigentlich ein selbsthilfe kurs ich saß kurz mit
drin genau also was ich gemacht hatte ist eigentlich ein aufruf zur selbsthilfe zu gpg
smart cards und die man die einrichten kann weil also dass die richtung jubi keys und mit
rucki ist zum beispiel mit denen man sie kurz von seinen schlüsseln die man zum beispiel nimmt für
E-Mail-Verschlüsselung einfach auf ein extra device auslagern kann und das hat den Vorteil,
dass man die ja nicht mehr verlieren kann. Zum Beispiel durch einen Trojaner, der irgendwas aus
seinem Home rauskopieren kann. Aber dafür Hardware kann man dann verlieren. Man kann die Software
nicht mehr verlieren. Also wenn man seinen Rechner ungeloggt lässt und einfach nur auf seine eigenen
Dateien kann, also jetzt mal Linux gesprochen in seinem Home, dann reicht das schon aus,
weil da sind die privaten Schlüssel immer frei zugänglich. Man kann natürlich mit Passwörtern
schützen und so weiter und so fort aber das ist alles relativ umständlich und
mit den wir haben den hafen und tun haben den vorteil die kann man abziehen mit
nehmen an den anderen rechner nehmen die man vielleicht nicht vertraut das heißt
ich habe mein private key zum verschlüsseln oder zum versignieren nur
auf diesem key und wenn ich damit was machen möchte dann sage ich quasi
schicke ich eine message an diesen key der verschlüsselt das für mich und
schickt mir dann das ergebnis wieder raus und ich habe nie auf meinem rechner
diesen key gehabt exakt so ist es genauso auch beim entschlüsseln tatsächlich
ja da brauchst du ja genau so den und das war im grunde um die sind ein bisschen schwierig
einzurichten weil also man hat dazu es gibt ein paar grafische oberflächen für sehr fixe arbeitsabläufe
und es gibt auch eine an command interface mit gpg oder gpg2 und aber das fühlt sich so ein
bisschen an die händisch mit dem ftp server reden und ja das ist halt uns gibt extrem viele
teilschritte und was gemacht hatte ist ich hatte einfach aus den verschiedenen
online anleitungen zusammen geschrieben was man machen kann
genau so ein kleines rezeptbuch und da aber sehr viele teilschritte sehr viele
teilfragen aufwerfen einfach die leute eingeladen sich mal zurück zu unterhalten
und hat sehr sehr viele kompetente leute angelockt und es war schön mit den
leuten reden es war eine mehr ahnung als ich es war ein mitarbeiter von nitro oder
nitro key da genauer und er hat den hatte ich bis dato noch gar nicht gehört ist das quasi sind die
auch austauschbar das gleiche system wie so ein jubikey oder ist das kannst du weißt du das genau
das ist ganz interessant also genau der alexander ist da der ist glaube ich zurzeit werkstudent oder
oder intern ein nidruck in schlauhe berlin sitzen die was sozusagen das deutsche pendant ist und
die haben im gegenteil zur jubikey tatsächlich noch die hardware die software komplett offen was
sehr schönes. Und genau,
über was wir geredet haben, ist die
OpenPGP-Schnittstelle.
Und die ist tatsächlich
austauschbar bei den richtigen
Smartcards. Also tatsächlich kann man sowohl
Nitro-Key als auch einen Yubi-Key nehmen
oder auch ganz andere. Es gibt die tatsächlich auch noch in
alten Check-Heft-Formaten.
Und die kann man tatsächlich
dann austauschen und mit dem gleichen Interface
mit denen reden. Das ist das Schöne, weil das standardisiert ist.
Ach, das ist geil. Ich nehme einen Key denn eigentlich
aus dem Ding drauf.
Den genereche ich ja wahrscheinlich immer noch selber. Den kaufe ich ja nicht mit dem
es gibt das würde ich als nächstes mal fragen es gibt zwei möglichkeiten du kannst den key auf dem
gerät generieren lassen okay dann kommt er dann hier runter oder du schmeißt speicher ist ein
dann auf da links zu denen aber auch nie wieder runter wenn du nicht woanders noch hast exakt das
hat aber unterschiedliche vornachteile die wir da auch mal kurz beleuchtet haben wenn ich das
richtig zusammenkriege die wenn du das auf dem gerät also du hast von ziemlich das fände ich
cool also das ziemlich coole moderation gemacht hast aber sofort wenn du was gesagt hast gesagt
correct me if I'm wrong oder bitte
sagt was dazu,
wenn ihr mehr wisst.
Das finde ich gut.
Ganz kurz.
Wir haben noch sieben Minuten,
bis wir hier raus sind.
Das können wir hin.
Oh, bis es bandvoll ist.
Das wusste ich gar nicht. Also wir haben eine Deadline.
Dann schmeißt uns einfach raus, dann müssen wir morgen weitermachen.
Wir können auch morgen weitermachen.
Die Vorteile, jetzt muss ich aufpassen,
dass ich mich schneller erinnere.
Die Vorteile
bei dem einen sind, wie gesagt, dass die Key nie
aus diesem Ding rauskriege, aber auf der anderen Seite muss ich halt die Hardware von diesem kleinen
Dings, was ich da an meinem Schlüsselbund hängen habe, nutzen, um den Key überhaupt zu erzeugen.
Und da gab es irgendwie vor kurzem so einen Bericht, dass die Hardware, die da verbaut ist,
nicht hinreichend ist. Kannst du dazu was erzählen? Ja, also ich bin grundsätzlich auch kein Fachmann.
Also ich möchte da jetzt auch nicht die verdrängen, aber grundsätzlich gab es da mehrere Probleme schon.
Also es gab schon mehrmals Probleme, dass man nicht genug Entropie auf den Geräten hat
und dass die Zufassgeneratoren schlecht implementiert sind. Das gab es schon öfter mal.
Und erst neulich war jetzt das Problem, das war glaube ich letzte Woche kam das raus, da war es ein Problem mit der RSA-Implementierung von, ich glaube Infineon, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, genau, Infineon und die waren bei YubiKey verbaut.
Und da ist genau das Problem, dass die Schlüssel, die erzeugt werden, vorhersagbar sind bei Schlüsseln, die das verbaut haben.
Und YubiKey und NitroKey sind also, die bauen auch nicht vom Sand hoch ihre Chips, sondern kaufen Sachen zu.
Und ich will sehen, der YubiKey 4, da gibt es einen Blogpost dazu vom Hersteller,
die verbauen die.
Das heißt, man sollte jetzt die Keys zumindest in der Generation,
also alle Keys, die vor Juni, glaube ich, gekauft sind, steht drin,
die haben den Fehler und die danach sind gefatcht und Nitro-Key ist nicht betroffen.
Okay, das heißt, ich gucke jetzt nach, welchen YubiKey ich habe.
Dann habe ich natürlich einen defekten YubiKey.
Ich denke, die meisten haben wir.
Also die haben schon still und leistens gepatcht vor ein paar Monaten,
bis es jetzt announced wurde.
Ja, gepatcht heißt, dass auf dem Modell, den du ab jetzt kaufst,
das ist halt ganz gut.
Exakt.
Das ist ja Hardware.
Ja, genau.
Ja, cool.
Was ich auch schön fand, ist, dass du
das alles, was du da erzählt hast in dem Workshop,
auch zusammengeschrieben hast und auch
Pro-Requests annimmst, damit man, also ich habe es leider
nicht geschafft, die ganze Zeit lang in dem Workshop
mit drin zu bleiben, aber ich kann es jetzt in Ruhe
nachlesen, wenn wir das alles zusammengeschrieben haben.
Genau, und wir haben jetzt auch sehr viel Input bekommen nochmal,
also auch nochmal andere Anleitungen, die ich davor noch nicht gefunden hatte
und die werde ich versuchen auch zusammenzutragen, zu verlinken.
Oder wenn jemand sagt, also wir hatten
speziell noch jemand, der hatte Installationsprobleme auf einem
Debian, was ich auch hatte, aber hatte eine andere Version von einem Key.
Und da ist der typische Works on My Device Problem, was tatsächlich dann auch die Überleitung ist in meinem Vortrag morgen.
Und ja, also da ist es interessant, einfach mit Leuten zusammenzukommen, überhaupt die Probleme zu sammeln und zu sehen.
Gibt es da irgendwelche unbedachten typischen Anwendungsfälle für solche Geräte, außer E-Mails-Verschlüsseln?
Ganz kurz davor, kannst du die URL mal kurz ins Mikro sagen, bevor du mal das führst?
Genau, die URL, also ich habe das hochgepusht auf GitHub, das unter meinem Account github.com.axel mit einer 3 statt 1 E.
sehr und dann ist das dort schon gepinnt das repository heißt gpg gpg unterstrich smartcard
genau das immer von profil ist die das mit oben rechts und ansonsten das wird auch gebaut das ist
auf read the docs das ist einfach gpg smartcard punkt redox io was macht man mit solchen geräten
außer e-mails und möglicherweise ein rechner entsperren genau also verschiedenste anwendungen
was man alles was man mit gpd auch so machen kann also geht kommentiert das
finde ich als software sehr wichtig dann klar locken anlocken verschlüsseln
entschlüsseln e-mails log ins ist ganz genau das ist aber eine extra funktion
tatsächlich also die hängt nicht unbedingt von gpg ab aber ist im grunde
das sind diese schlüssel genau das haben die oft jetzt auch schon als extra
funktion mit drauf und manche können nfc dann kannst du dein telefon damit den schlüssel genau
was zu bescheuert ist weil wenn du dein telefon und deinen schlüssel liegen lässt dann kann jemand
einfach dein telefon an dein schlüssel ja genau wo ich da jetzt tatsächlich auch versuche das auf
einen usb-anschluss zu machen weil ich wollte größere schlüsselgrößen nehmen und das geht
anscheinend soweit sich gelesen habe über das internet über nfc nicht mehr so gut bei dem relativ
große bandpreise dafür brauchst und da kann man einfach unten anstecken und das entsprechend
benutzen dann habe ich jetzt die aufzeichnung bevor wir hier komplett rausfliegen hast du
jetzt den monitor mit einem pulli zugehören das hilft überhaupt nichts aber dieser kleine junge
schreibt die ganze zeit in diese gesprächernlage und ich erschreck mich immer so ein bisschen wie
im verhörraum weißt du nur dass die ich halt nach der scheinwerfer ja und dass die scheibe
verspiegelt sein also wir sehen sozusagen der spiegel hat gehusteten ein
das ist ein alter spiegel erknarzt noch manchmal
spiegel hat gewusst
vielleicht sind wir ja auch die beobachter und da drin sind die arten
ich sitze jetzt hier gerade mit zwei leuten die ich noch gar nicht kenne ihr
seid auch auf den datenspuren unterwegs könnt ihr euch mal kurz vorstellen was
macht ihr denn so? Ja, ich bin Katharina, ich heiße Katharina und das ist Markus und
wir haben eben im Museumskino einen Vortrag gehalten und wurden dann hier hoch zitiert
und freuen uns, dass wir jetzt mit dir hier im Tonstudio sitzen. Im Tonstudio sitzen ist
übelst cool, das ist auch das erste Mal für mich. Worüber habt ihr einen Vortrag gehalten?
Der Titel war "Mit Datenskulpturen im virtuellen Kosmos".
Wir sind zwei von einem insgesamt 17-köpfigen Team.
Wir haben ein medienkünstlerisches Projekt entwickelt die letzten anderthalb Jahre.
Das nennt sich Cosmotic und ist quasi eine multisensorische,
intraaktive Installation in einer virtuellen Umgebung.
Das waren jetzt ganz viele.
Du hast die ganze Präsentation auswendig gelernt.
Das heißt also, ihr seid Künstler?
Sie ist Künstlerin, also Kadas Künstlerin.
Ich bin Informatiker, also ich repräsentiere praktisch die technische Seite des Projekts
und von Katharina dann die künstlerische und überhaupt die Idee des Projekts hatte.
Und euer 17-köpfiges Team, wie setzt sich das zusammen?
Unter was für einem Rahmen läuft das?
Wir hatten, also quasi hatte ich das, wir sind Teil von Neueräume, Neueräume.xyz, da ist unsere Homepage.
Da sieht man auch, kann man aktuell mitverfolgen, was wir machen.
Wir haben ein Konzept geschrieben, wir wollten quasi wissen, was ist diese VR-Medientechnologie, was kann man damit anstellen?
Genau, die Brille, was macht die mit uns? Die soll ja so immersiv wirken.
Genau, da haben wir ein Konzept geschrieben, sind gefördert von der Stadt Dresden, vom Kulturamt und von der Kulturstiftung Sachsen und hatten dann ein bisschen Kohle sozusagen, um das Team Margot zu bezahlen und die Technik anzuschaffen.
Und ja, das sind weitere Softwareentwickler, die diese virtuelle Umgebung geschaffen haben.
Ganz wichtiges Element ist der Datenhandschuh.
Also wir verbinden VR-Technologie mit weiterer erweiterte Sensortechnologie.
Da kommt dann Markus quasi ins Spiel als unser Sensormensch.
Und genau, naja, und dann Produktdesigner, PR-Frau, also alles, was so ein Projekt hat.
Also quasi für dieses Projekt neu zusammengewürfelte Leute.
Na, mit Markus, wir haben schon zusammen vorher in einem Projekt gearbeitet.
Wir kannten uns schon.
Also da gab es mal ein Projekt, das war uniübergreifend hier in Dresden.
Das war von der HTW Dresden, von der TU Dresden und von der HFBK.
Da sollten einfach mal Informatiker mit Künstlern und anderen Feldern einfach mal zusammenkommen.
Also die wurden einfach mal zusammen in den Raum geschmissen.
Da wurden ein paar Workshops gemacht über Kunst, Technik und so weiter.
Und dann konnten wir uns zusammen halt irgendwelche coolen Projekte irgendwie ausdenken.
Und Katharina hatte da ihr Tagebuch oder wie soll man es?
Der unsichtbare Faden, ja, da ging es so ein bisschen darum, seinen eigenen Geist abzuladen.
Also die Seite ist auch nach wie vor online, ist auch spielerisch begehbar quasi.
dieses virtuelle Tagebuch in Anführungsstrichen.
Und das hatte mir Markus und damals noch der Mario.
Genau.
Genau, die hatten mir das technisch realisiert.
Das heißt, ihr habt hier auf den Datenspuren unten im,
oben, wir sind hier gerade im dritten Stock,
oben im vierten Stock,
diese gesamten Installationen da aufgebaut,
die man sich angucken könnte?
Nein.
Also dadurch, dass Cosmotic, also unser Projekt, sehr sensibel ist, aufgrund der ganzen Sensorik, dem Datenhalschuh, dem VR-Helm, den wir extra entwickelt haben.
Also dieses ganze System ist sehr sensibel, aufgrund auch seiner Komplexität, weshalb es ständige Betreuung braucht.
Und das kann man nicht so einfach irgendwo hinstellen und dann benutzen das die Leute.
Sondern wir werden erst am 11. und 12. November im Raum Cool X, also am Ende dieser When Machines are Dreaming Ausstellung,
dann an dem letzten Wochenende quasi Kosmotik präsentieren im Raum Cool X.
Wo ist das?
Das ist im dritten Stock, also auf unserer Ebene gerade.
Auch hier in den technischen Sammlungen?
Richtig, auch hier in den technischen Sammlungen.
Genau, da ist ja dann 11. oder 12. November der Multimedia-Jugendpreis MB21 und die sind
dann auch hier und da sind dann ganz viele Kinder und Jugendliche hier und da ist dann
nochmal ordentlich Bambule in dem Haus, so wie heute und gestern hier auch. Genau und
da präsentieren wir dann Kosmotik.
Okay, also euer Projekt heißt Kosmotik?
Ja.
Und ihr habt diese Installation mit VR und Datenhandschuhen gemacht und darüber habt
ihr heute vorhin in vortrag gehalten genau wir sind ja hier thema datenspuren und ja seine eigenen
daten auszulesen den schritt zähler da am tag wie viele schritte habe ich gemacht den pulsträcker
wie groß mein puls oder was habe ich gegessen wie viele kalorien habe ich heute verbrannt also
sich selber zu vermessen das ist ja eine soziale realität wie wir finden und was für yourself
Genau, Quantify Yourself, das ist der Schlachtruf. Und wir haben uns quasi dazu Gedanken gemacht, was denn jetzt dieses VR-Medium, also diese virtuelle Realität, was dieses Medium, wie wir dort diese soziale Realität hineintransportieren können und was dieses Medium unter Umständen daraus macht.
Denn wie der eine oder andere schon erfahren hat, haben wir dort auf einmal einen gesamten Raum zur Verfügung.
Und man muss sich nochmal überlegen, was passieren würde, wenn wir anstelle von Statistiken und Diagrammen das auf einmal räumlich begehbar machen.
Da kriegt man ganz andere Relationen dazu.
Das heißt, ihr habt euch Konzepte ausgedacht, wie man dieses über den Körper, über einen selbst gesammelten Daten innerhalb von dieser VR-Umgebung interaktiv erfahrbar machen kann.
Richtig, wie diese ästhetisch, also wahrnehmbar, wie Daten wahrnehmbar gemacht werden können, auf eine spielerische Art und Weise.
Wie kann ich mir das vorstellen, so grob, an einem konkreten einzelnen Beispiel?
Na, zum Beispiel haben wir einen Asteroiden in diesem Kosmos und da drin wird man durchbewegt.
Das ist wie so eine Art Achterbahnfahrt und die Geschwindigkeit dieser Fahrt bestimmt deinen Hautleitwert.
Und der Hautleitwert ist so ein Indikator für dein Stresslevel.
Wie so ein Lügen-Detector quasi.
Im Prinzip wird einfach praktisch der Widerstand auf deiner Haut gemessen, also der elektrische Widerstand.
Und wenn ich jetzt gestresst bin und viel schwitze, dann werden meine Hände ja feuchter und dadurch fließt der Strom leichter.
Und da kann ich das einfach nicht mehr.
Kann ich halt die Achterbahn noch schneller und dann hatte ich noch gestresst.
Genau, genau.
Also das ist so ein Punkt, wo wir es wirklich mal provozierend nutzen, dieses Biofeedback.
Aber an einem anderen Element wie der Datenskulptur, wo man seine eigene Atmung beobachtet,
dass die Fragmente mit der Einatmung sich zusammenziehen und mit der Ausatmung auseinander trifft.
wenn man da so einer mannsgroßen Skulptur gegenübersteht, die sich genauso bewegt wie du selber.
Das sind also Live-Daten, an denen ihr dann gerade arbeitet.
Es ist nicht so, dass man vorher irgendwie das, was man in der Apple Watch gesammelt hat, abgibt
und das irgendwie in Diagrammen an virtuelle Wände projiziert,
sondern das ist tatsächlich das, was gerade über einen gemessen wird.
Dazu hat Markus eben einen Datenhandschuh entwickelt und sich dazu Gedanken gemacht
oder das realisiert, wie jetzt überhaupt diese Daten, diese Rohdaten ausgelesen werden können,
damit sie dann innerhalb meiner Überlegungen auch ästhetisch interpretiert werden können.
Das ist auch noch relativ einfach so, dass man es vielleicht auch mal nachbauen kann und
einfach selbst zuhause mal testen kann. Können wir mal ganz kurz konkret über die Technik reden?
Was benutzt ihr zum Beispiel für diese VR-Umgebung? Also wir haben die HTC Vive,
diese VR-Brille hält und mit Unity das war durch die Game Engine, mit dem man halt Sachen
entwickeln kann dafür.
Für den Datenhandschuh haben wir eigentlich Arduino, also diese Mikrocontroller, die eigentlich
auch vor allem für Kinder und Jugendliche halt gedacht sind, einfach Projekte zu machen.
Und dafür gibt es sehr unzählig viele Sensoren schon, also so einen Pulssensor gibt es da
auch schon für, also wenn man das Original kauft für ich glaube 25 Euro oder aus China,
wie es heutzutage viele Leute machen, dann für 3-4 Euro.
Also es gibt bereits einen Arduino Pulssensor und einen Arduino Hautlight.
Naja, da misst man einfach nur einen Widerstand.
Also wir haben dann praktisch einen Handschuh entwickelt, der am Anfang einfach zwei Unterlegscheiben aus Metall hatte als Elektroden
und dort einfach zwischen diesen zwei Unterlegscheiben den Widerstand gemessen hat.
Es ging ein bisschen blöd, deswegen haben wir dann später einen gestrickten Handschuh gehabt
und dort waren einfach mit Metallgarn zwei Stellen als Elektroden gestrickt und miteinander verfundet.
Da habt ihr mit Metall gestrickt oder nicht?
Genau, also so ein Garn, wo Silberfäden oder Stahlfäden, bin ich mir jetzt ganz sicher.
Es war Silver Conductive.
Das kriegt man, wenn man sich Arduino-Zubehör ansieht, kommt man dann schnell auf solche Sachen,
die man auch dann in Kleidung sehr gut einbauen kann.
Abgefahren, abgefahren.
Ja genau, ein Temperatursensor, der halt noch die Hauttemperatur misst und ein Atemsensor, der sich aber an der Nase befindet und dort einfach die, also es ist im Prinzip einfach nur ein Temperatursensor, der nur misst, atmet man jetzt aus, erwärmt er sich, atmet man ein, kühlt er sich ab bei Umgebungsluft, bei Raumtemperatur.
Problem hatten wir dann, hat immer ziemlich gut funktioniert. Problematisch war dann auf einmal im Sommer, als die Raumtemperatur ungefähr der Atemtemperatur entsprach und dann funktionierte das System nicht mehr. Da mussten wir dann noch auf ein paar andere Tricks zurückgreifen. Zum Beispiel, also in dem Fall war es halt ein Windsensor, der ist immer auf einer Temperatur von, ich glaube, 60 Grad Celsius und der kühlt sich dann beim Ein- und beim Ausatmen halt jeweils ab.
Man konnte eigentlich nicht mehr so gut unterscheiden, ob man jetzt aus- oder einatmet,
aber zumindest konnte man die Atmung überhaupt erst mal wieder darstellen.
Wir haben es dann nochmal mit einem Mikrofon probiert, weil der Windsensor leider durchgebrannt
war und wir mussten dann schnell den Ersatz finden.
Ja, also viel rumprobiert und das Ganze kann man sicherlich noch deutlich verbessern, aber
es hat erstmal gut funktioniert eigentlich.
Ah, das ist cool.
Wie seid ihr dazu gekommen das zu machen?
Also du bist Künstlerin, bist du irgendwie als Künstlerin tätig?
Ja, als Medienkünstlerin, neues Medium.
Ich komme ja eigentlich aus einem Animationsfilm, aus dem Narrativen.
Das heißt du hast vorher Animationsfilme gemacht?
Ich habe vorher Animation gemacht, hatte dann mit Markus mein erstes webbasiertes Projekt.
Und mir geht es halt darum, was sind jetzt Medien, die irgendwas machen, wenn man da was reingibt und bringt dann noch ihre eigenen Erkenntnisse und Färbungen mit rein.
Und was ist jetzt eben bei der VR-Technologie?
Und ja, die VR-Brille ist auch erstmal so ein visueller Apparat.
Und ich habe mir einfach, was ist das für ein Apparat?
Und der Herr Schreiber, auch meine Doktorarbeit darüber.
Sodass Kosmotik auch in der Form meiner Experimentalanordnung ist für meine medienphilosophische Auseinandersetzung.
Ah, super spannend.
An der Bauhaus-Uni in Weimar.
Genau. Und ja, um mal so ein bisschen den Schluss vielleicht auch für unseren Vortrag zu finden.
Markus hat da eben den Datenhandschuh, den Bau vorgestellt und ich dann so die einzelnen Elemente,
wie wir die Daten ästhetisch interpretiert haben, gezeigt anhand von Screen-Videos.
Und naja, eigentlich das, worauf man, weil du vorhin das Quantified-Self gesagt hast,
ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das Credo,
dass eigentlich ohne Kontext oder ohne bedeutungsvolles Spielen
jede Datenerfassung eigentlich nur die halbe Geschichte oder eine unvollständige Geschichte erzählt,
weil letzten Endes braucht es die persönliche Erfahrung oder überhaupt die Beschreibung.
Warum bin ich jetzt in meiner Leistung so abgefallen?
Ja klar, weil ich mir einen Fuß gebrochen habe. Das kriegt natürlich die App, zeigt das jetzt nicht mit an.
Also erst das Qualified Self komplementiert dann eigentlich die gemessenen und gesammelten Daten.
Und da tragt ihr mit eurem Projekt zu bei?
Ja, das war quasi die Fragestellung und ließ sich jetzt experimentell auch ganz gut bestätigen.
Das ist super cool. Das heißt, die Leute können sich das hier in Dresden am 11. November, hast du gesagt?
11.12. November hier in den Technischen Sammlungen im Raum QLX.
Können Sie das erleben.
Also nochmal jetzt, ich hoffe, wir veröffentlichen diese Aufnahme bis dahin,
kommt am 11.12. November hier in die Technischen Sammlungen nach Dresden
und schaut euch das Projekt von den beiden hier an.
Vielen Dank für dieses Gespräch.
Wenn Leute nochmal konkrete Fragen dazu haben, wo würden sie euch finden oder kontaktieren können?
Am besten im Internet natürlich.
Das Internet.
Das Internet?
Ja, unter www.neueräume.xyz
oder post.at
www.neueräume.xyz
Da könnt ihr dann uns anschreiben
bei Fragen, Interesse oder
was auch immer.
Was euch halt im Herzen liegt.
Okay.
Ja, super spannend. Vielen lieben Dank für dieses Gespräch.
Danke.
Und ich wünsche euch noch schöne Doppenspuren.
Euch auch.
Seid ihr fertig?
Ja.
Also können wir die Aufnahme stoppen?
Ja, sehr gern.
Okay, dann mache ich auch die Tür auf, dass ich wieder Luft kriege.
Vielen Dank.
Seid ihr damit einverstanden, dass ich die Aufnahme hinterher in meinem Podcast veröffentliche?
Ja, ich würde vorschlagen, wir schmeißen die ganzen Schnipsel in eine Tonne und jeder nimmt sich davon, was er will.
Das klingt dann, damit kann ich leben.
Dann sollten wir langsam anfangen.
Dürfen wir?
Der Chef guckt doch mal drüber, aber es sieht insgesamt sehr gut aus.
Also nein.
Heißt das, wir können kontinuieren?
Ja, akronomisierbar, Sondersendung auf den Datenspuren.
Wir sitzen hier gerade zusammen mit Sandro, Nack und Mandy.
Hallo.
Ihr seid hier auf den Datenspuren ganz viel unterwegs und ihr haltet ganz viele Vorträge
zu unterschiedlichen Themen.
Könnt ihr mal ein bisschen was zu euch erzählen?
Was macht ihr hier eigentlich?
Okay, da fange ich mal an, der Sandro.
Und zwar gemeinsam mit dem Nackt, der hier neben mir sitzt, habe ich im letzten Jahr ein
kleines Pilotprojekt gestartet.
Wir arbeiten beide im Bereich Medienpädagogik schon seit einigen Jahren und dachten uns,
das sollten wir mal versuchen, ob das vielleicht auch Interessenten bei den Datenspuren gibt,
wo die sagen, okay, Thema kann man dorthin probieren, hinbasteln.
Und da haben wir einfach im letzten Jahr einen Talk gehalten, gemeinsam und von den erwarteten
drei leuten die kommen dann plötzlich 30 da und dachten wir uns okay thema ist
scheinbar doch irgendwie von interesse und dieses jahr haben ein bisschen
größer aufgezogen haben jetzt fünf talks insgesamt zusammen gesammelt und
noch dazu eine praxis workshop wo mein test gespielt wird wie ist der talk
letztes jahr letztes jahr war es datenunterricht und
hackspace für for kids die überschrift war pädagogik und technik vernetzt oder
so genau also datenspuren thema letztes jahr war halt schwer vernetzt und daran wollte mir
anknüpfen haben gesagt ja pädagogik und technik vernetzt und da haben sich dann die zwei talks
innerhalb eines talks untergeordnet nämlich einmal sein datenunterricht und zum anderen meine idee
von hackspace for kids ich frage das weil es wahrscheinlich eine aufzeichnung vom letzten
jahr gibt falls ich das jemand doch mal angucken möchte leider nicht oder das video ist bei dir
gelandet. Ja, und war dann irgendwie nicht
bearbeitet. Also offiziell leider nicht, die Videoengel
haben es nicht geschafft, sozusagen unsere Talks mit aufzunehmen.
Deswegen redet er ja dieses Jahr nochmal.
Ja, aber auch wieder in dem Raum,
wo die Videoengel nicht waren. Das heißt,
unsere Talks sind nicht aufgezeichnet worden, nur einer,
den ich heute im Museumskino gehalten habe.
Dann müsstest du uns das jetzt alles hier erzählen.
Ganz viel Zeit haben wir.
Genug.
Okay, wollen wir einfach mal die Reihe rummachen?
Gerne, erzähl mal ein bisschen was
über euch.
Ich bin der Nack.
ich bin so ein Wusel so ein bisschen im Chaos Computer Club Dresden rum und habe halt
Verschiedenes in meinem Leben gemacht. Ich habe eine Ausbildung in Richtung Programmierung
gemacht. Das hat allerdings abgebrochen, weil es irgendwie mein Hobby kaputt gemacht hat,
nämlich Technik. Dann bin ich in die Pädagogik eingestiegen, habe mal ein Jahr ehrenamtlich
in der Kita gearbeitet, habe einen Sozialassistenten gemacht, Fachhabitur gemacht für Sozialwesen,
bin an Mathe gescheitert und habe dann gemerkt, ja, okay, irgendwie, ja, sonst,
du was richtiges machen? Also habe ich in der Erzieher angefangen.
Und in der Erzieherausbildung war ich nach
einem halben Jahr so frustriert, dass ich gesagt habe,
nein, das ist für mich nicht der richtige Weg.
Und habe dann
erstmal irgendwie so eine Selbstfindungsphase gehabt und
ja, bin dann
etwas später auf Sandro gestoßen
durch mehr oder weniger Zufall
und seitdem sind wir ein bisschen
gemeinsam unterwegs und haben dann
irgendwann mal unsere nette Begleitung hier
aufgegabelt, die uns unterstützt und
uns was guten Feedback gibt.
Ja.
und zu den letzten Datenspuren hatte ich halt
vorher die Idee, wie kann
man Kinder und Jugendliche an Technik ranführen
und mein Grundgedanke war,
eigentlich müssen wir sie in die Hackspaces auch reinlassen.
So Hackspaces sind halt manchmal
ein bisschen Elfenbeinturm, Flair,
so wir halten uns für super intelligent
und super schlau, das sind wir in gewisser
Weise natürlich auch,
aber
ja. Es wirkt halt nicht unbedingt einladend
manchmal auf Leute, die komplett von
durch anfangen. Nicht nur das, halt auch
Solche Events wie die Datenspuren, Kongress oder anderes, Camp,
es sind halt extrem fachliche Themen,
aber die gesellschaftlichen Themen, die durchaus auch da sind
und über die berichtet wird, geht dann meistens auch stark ins Politische über.
Also Medienpädagogik hat bisher wenig Einzug gehalten.
Auf dem Kongress gab es auch Talks darüber, aber verhältnismäßig wenig.
Und daher hatte ich den Gedanken,
ja, ich würde gerne einen Talk auf den Datenspuren halten,
aber ich möchte das nicht allein machen.
Und da habe ich meinen netten Sandro gefunden
und dann haben wir es zusammen gemacht.
Und ich glaube, das hat uns beiden auch genug Sicherheit gegeben,
das zu tun.
Es haben ja auch nicht viele Leute diese Kombination im Hintergrund.
Also sozial arbeiten und gleichzeitig so einen technischen Hacker-Hintergrund.
Das ist keine Vorstellung, wie schlimm das ist.
Nein, ohne Scheiß.
Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Weil egal, auf welcher Seite du stehst, du hast es schwer.
Also Sandro kann das aus einer anderen Perspektive noch berichten,
aber es ist schlimm.
Es ist wirklich schlimm.
Egal welche Seite.
Also fühlt ihr da quasi so eine Marktlücke?
Ich sage mal, es ist ein gesellschaftlicher Bereich, der wenig beleuchtet ist und den wir erstmal uns genau anschauen müssen
und dann vielleicht daraus Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen, um dann vielleicht politisch agieren zu können.
Das ist der große Plan.
An sich heißt es aber, das merke ich nur bei dem, was ich die ganze Zeit auch mache und auch unterrichte,
wir müssen erstmal auch ganz nah an der Praxis am Alltag wirklich anfangen.
Jugendliche und Kinder haben sozusagen schon einen immensen Zugang zu Technik.
Sie nutzen sie ganz intensiv und haben aber eigentlich keinerlei Möglichkeiten, Leute
zu fragen, wie sie es eigentlich richtig tun.
Sie haben keine Hilfestellung, weil die Generationen darüber, ihre Eltern, sind noch mehr Dau als
die Kinder.
Und das haben wir ein Problem.
Wir haben da gesellschaftlich ein riesen großes Problem und eigentlich könnten Schulen dafür
einspringen, aber sie tun es nicht.
Jetzt würde ich noch mal ganz kurz Mandy ansprechen, bevor wir dich hier vergessen,
bevor wir weiter über die Themen sprechen.
Alles gut, ja. Ich bin die erwähnte nette Begleitung.
Ich bin Mandy. Ich bin Sozialpädagogin vom Abschluss her,
also war jetzt aber noch nicht in der Praxis tätig.
Ich arbeite aktuell an der Uni und bin dort auch in der Lehramtsausbildung beteiligt,
an einer Professur für Medienpädagogik, wo es eben genau um diese Themen geht.
Und ich war letztes Jahr, weil es mich einfach selber interessiert,
das erste Mal auf den Datenspuren und habe mich gleich von dem Talk
zu Pädagogik und Technik anziehen lassen und seitdem habe ich mit Sandro und Nack auch zu tun,
so dass wir jetzt immer mal uns auch zu verschiedenen Sachen getroffen haben und uns absprechen, was wir machen.
Und gestern auf den Datenspuren bin ich nur kurzfristig eingesprungen und habe selber noch einen Talk gehalten
zu medienpädagogischer Projektarbeit, habe da ein paar Anregungen reingegeben, wo man Ideen findet
und dass jeder sich das trauen sollte, mal was auszuprobieren, ob er nur Pädagogin ist oder nicht.
dass es eigentlich nicht so schwierig ist.
Also was ich da, was ich vielleicht noch kurz ergänzen möchte,
während wir eher so von beiden Seiten, von der Technik wie auch von der Pädagogik,
immer nur einen Teil mitbringen, ergänzt sie halt das exzellent durch ihre pädagogische Sichtweise.
Also hat uns auch guten Input dahingehend schon gegeben.
Also das ist auch nochmal etwas, was unser Team, glaube ich, sehr bereichert hat auch.
Also ihr ergänzt euch sehr gut?
Ja.
Ja, doch.
Also wir sind jetzt hier auf den Datenspuren und ihr hattet mehrere Vorträge, das haben
wir jetzt schon erwähnt.
Könnt ihr mal erzählen, worüber ihr geredet habt konkret?
Also grundsätzlich haben wir damit angefangen zu überlegen, ja wir wollen mehrere Talkseiten.
Da haben wir geschaut, was für Möglichkeiten haben wir, wen haben wir, wer möchte und
haben dann versucht ein Rahmenprogramm aufzubauen.
Und das fing dann halt ursprünglich an damit, dass die Mediensucht, wie hieß sie?
Peggy.
Peggy über Mediensucht spricht, Ines über Gamification, Sandro über Minecraft in der
Schule und ich dann sozusagen über meinen Test.
Also Peggy und Ines sind jetzt zwei, die auch mit bei euch im Team sind quasi?
Die jetzt ein bisschen dazu gestoßen sind.
Wir werden sehen, wie sich das weiterentwickelt.
So jetzt einfach mal.
Also ich hatte mit beiden Frauen.
Du bist gerade hier nicht mit im Raum für den Hörer.
Genau.
Ich hatte mit beiden vorher noch nicht so viel zu tun, aber mal schauen, vielleicht ändert sich das jetzt auch.
Genau, das waren einfach zwei Leute, die schon seit der ganzen grauen Zeit in diesen Bereichen unterwegs sind
und die wir halt auch eingeladen haben, damit ihr nicht alle Talks selber halten müsst.
Weil wir es noch gar nicht können.
Und welche Talks habt ihr selber gehalten?
Genau, da fange ich gleich einfach mal an.
Mein Talk über, also ich habe zwei gehalten, einen gestern über Minecraft.
Und zwar unterrichte ich ja schon seit 5, 6 Jahren an der Freien Autentivschule hier in Dresden.
Minecraft als Unterrichtsfach.
Minecraft als Unterrichtsfach?
Ja, genau. Und darüber habe ich einfach berichtet, wie das Ganze abläuft, weil viele gucken genau so, auch jetzt für die Hörerinnen wieder, wie was du unterrichtest, irgendwie Computer spielst du, unterrichtest Minecraft, ja, das tue ich.
Das ist aber kein Architekturkurs.
Nein, es geht tatsächlich wirklich nur darum, dass Jugendliche Schülerin gemeinsam spielen.
Und da habe ich eben ein bisschen erzählt, wie es dazu kam, warum es überhaupt möglich ist, dass sozusagen auch die Resonanz der Schülerin einfach ist und wie das wirklich auch abläuft.
Da habe ich auch recht viel berichtet und meine Schlussfolgerungen rausgezogen und ganz am Ende natürlich ganz klar gesagt, Leute, wir müssen spielen.
Wir müssen auch in der Schule spielen, wir dürfen uns nicht verteufeln.
Das heißt nicht sozusagen, dass wir sagen müssen, okay, bitte, das mit dem Spielen ist total super, wir spielen unser ganzes Leben lang, sondern wir müssen einfach begleiten, wir müssen erstmal dabei sein.
Das ist eine ganz wichtige Erfahrung daraus.
Wir sind noch gar nicht dabei, eigentlich pädagogisch sozusagen wirklich gut zu arbeiten, sondern wir sind eigentlich erstmal dabei, noch zu gucken, was passiert denn da eigentlich?
Also wir rennen immer hinterher.
Also jetzt sind wir eigentlich noch bei den Sozialwissenschaften, die analysieren,
um es dann an die Pädagogen zu geben, die dann vielleicht Konzepte entwickeln,
um dann bei der Politik anzufragen, ihr habt ja auch Kohle dafür, könnt ihr es bitte umsetzen.
So, und wenn wir jetzt den Prozess jetzt angucken und dann dazu vergleichen,
wie Jugendliche heutzutage aufwachsen, dann hinken wir schon Jahrzehnte hinterher.
Ist ein Riesenproblem.
Und das habe ich versucht, neben dem rein darstellen, was da eigentlich passiert,
sozusagen mit rüberzubringen.
Legt das irgendwie daran, dass die Kinder, ich weiß nicht, ich spekuliere jetzt, dass Kinder eigentlich schon immer viel miteinander gespielt haben auf dem Schulhof und das jetzt vielleicht weniger machen, weil es mehr Computerspiele gibt?
Dass man das irgendwie wieder zusammenführen muss, dass sie, wenn sie Computerspiele spielen, dass sie dann gemeinsam spielen?
Also das sehe ich nicht so. Also Kinder spielen durchaus zusammen. Es erweitert sich halt nur. Also das Spielfeld erweitert sich. Es ist halt jetzt nicht nur der Sandkasten, es gibt halt jetzt auch digitale Spielräume.
Und das ist halt etwas, was Sanu geschaffen hat.
Und da ist es wichtig, was du angesprochen hast, es geht tatsächlich um das gemeinsame
Spielen.
Also zum Beispiel in diesem Minecraft-Unterricht, da spielen wir auch nicht auf externen Servern
und alle einzelnen irgendwelchen Welten, sondern ich lege Wert darauf, dass wir in einer gemeinsamen
Welt spielen, wo auch alle drin sind, die im Raum sind.
Digitaler Sandkasten.
Ganz genau.
Und dort ist mir auch das Wichtige, also jetzt auch zu den aktuellen Buzzwords wie Hate Speech
und ähnliches, dass Menschen einfach mal verstehen, dass hinter dem Pixelhaufen, den sie gerade
da niederschlachten, dass dahinter ein Mensch steht, dem es vielleicht nicht gefällt, der
vielleicht schlecht drauf ist, der vielleicht gut drauf ist, der vielleicht irgendwie mein
Freund sein könnte oder eben auch gerade nicht.
Und in dem Moment, wo wir aber noch gemeinsam in einem Raum sitzen, da reagieren natürlich
Schülerinnen erstmal anders, als wenn es irgendwo im Netz stattfindet.
Schlichtweg auch eine Tatsache, weil die Personen, die ich da gerade irgendwie niedermetzle,
die können doch mal auf den Tisch rumkommen.
Dann haben wir vielleicht ein anderes Problem.
Während im Netz ist alles anonymen, was soll da passieren?
Eine Dossertag, okay, gut, aber an sich, da kann ja nichts passieren.
Und genau darum geht es, dass man jungen Menschen beibringt, okay, dass dieser Pixelhaufen ist
tatsächlich ein Mensch dahinter.
Das ist ein ganz zentrales Moment und daher auch ganz wichtig, gemeinsam zu spielen.
Und natürlich die anderen positiven Effekte auch,
dass gemeinsam viele Dinge besser gehen und so weiter.
Und das Horten von Diamanten alleine auch keinen Spaß macht,
sondern dass man da schon irgendwie auch gemeinsam viel mehr Dinge erreichen kann.
Das ist eine interessante Sensibilisierung auf jeden Fall,
um darauf zu achten, dass man mit Menschen spielt und die auch als Menschen zu sehen.
Ganz genau.
Und da habt ihr ja auch eine Installation aufgebaut von Dungeonsporn?
Da habt ihr ganz viele Laptops reingeschleppt?
Also, ja, also Sanu macht halt Minecraft.
Ich habe mir das bei ihm in seiner Schule halt angeschaut.
Hab das auch ein bisschen kritischer gesehen, als das Sandow vielleicht gesehen hat.
Und hab mir überlegt, ja, was könnten noch für schon mögliche Probleme sein?
Minecraft ist halt proprietär, wir müssen Lizenzkosten haben.
Also es gibt halt Lizenzkosten.
Und Minecraft ist halt in Java geschrieben, was bedeutet, dass es relativ hartwerbhungig ist.
Und hab mich dann nach Alternativen umgeschaut und bin auf meinen Test gestoßen.
Also ich kannte es vorher schon, aber hab es dann erst wahrgenommen als pädagogische Methode für so etwas.
Und habe dann halt angefangen, mir Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie man das dann pädagogisch auch einsetzen könnte.
Dass das Gleichbedeutende mit Sandbox Minecraft Werkstatt wäre.
Und bin mittlerweile zu der Tatsache gekommen, ja, das ist es.
Und dementsprechend haben wir heute beide Tage einen Mindtest-Schnitt aufgebaut.
Genau, und da haben wir oben ein paar Rechner, also so um die 15 Rechner ungefähr, auf denen das Spiel quasi läuft.
Wir haben auch einen kleinen Server, wo die genau in dieser digitalen Sandkiste sich austoben können.
Wir laden die Eltern, die mitkommen, ein, sich mit dazu zu setzen, selber zu spielen, sich von ihren Kindern zeigen zu lassen, was sie da eigentlich machen, das gemeinsam zu entdecken und animieren die Gruppe eben auch, dass sie was zusammenbauen.
Wir haben jetzt beispielsweise das Gebäude der technischen Sammlungen schon nachgebaut. Ich glaube, gerade eben entsteht auch noch ein kleines Pesthörnchen.
Also da ist wirklich viel los und es kommt gut an. Man kann das Programm einfach als Alternative aufzeigen und auch anstupsen für die Pädagogen, die vorbeigucken, was man damit eigentlich machen kann.
Ich habe das schon gesehen, aber ihr habt da so einen großen Bildschirm und da kann man
gucken, was ihr schon alles an Gebäuden geschaffen habt, seit gestern.
Genau.
Der Vorteil meint, es ist halt freie Software.
Es ist in C++ geschrieben, die Mods sind in Loa geschrieben.
Sprich, du kannst halt relativ simpel da auch Programmierkurse anbieten, was in Minecraft
eher etwas noch komplizierter ist.
Und damit bietet sich halt auch eine größere Vielfalt an Angebote, die man da ausformulieren
kann.
stehen wir halt auch noch komplett am anfang das heißt ihr habt jetzt noch keine wie keine schulkurse
nachmittagskurse gemacht wie schreibe ich meine eigenen main test mods also es sollte eigentlich
ursprünglich hier auch einen workshop geben zum motto entwicklung das ist ein bisschen aufgrund
der zeit und der tatsache dass es halt alles ein bisschen drunter und rüber ging wir mussten halt
auch noch lernen wie das mit der aura noch ein bisschen besser funktioniert hat das leider nicht
stattgefunden. Das sind ja auch
bloß zwei Tage.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen, aber
ja, ich habe halt angefangen,
ein Ganztags-Konzept dafür zu entwickeln.
Also ich würde damit gerne
ein Ganztags-Angebot an Schulen anbieten wollen.
Damit halt auch ein kleines bisschen mein Leben
finanzieren wollen, nebenbei.
Und ja,
aber da liegt noch viel Arbeit
von mir. Und ich freue mich übrigens sehr über
Input. Also wenn irgendjemand da Interesse hat
oder so, gerne könnt ihr mir schreiben.
Perfekte Möglichkeit, Motivation zu schaffen, wenn man Leuten oder Kindern nahelegt, dann
da zu modden irgendwann, da rein zu treffen, deine eigenen Inhalte zu erweitern und das
zugänglich eben hat durch eine offene Plattform, durch Lua als einfache Skriptsprache.
Ich meine, Spiele sind schon immer der Weg, wie Leute oft zur Informatik finden.
Nicht nur das, also ich habe mich gefragt, freies Spiel ist ein Begriff in der Pädagogik,
besonders in der Kita oder so, wo es darum geht, dass Kinder möglichst frei an ihre Spielmaterialien
materiell herankommen, sich frei beschäftigen können, freie Konflikte
ausleben können, auch ohne dass ein Erwachsener eingreift und sich einfach
frei entfalten können. Sie können durch ihren eigenen Ablauf am besten
lernen, durch ihre eigene Motivation. Und daher ist Spielen halt unglaublich
wichtig. Spielen ist für uns alle wichtig. Jeder Mensch spielt, selbst meine
Oma spielt. Also und das ist halt ein perfektes Medium.
Ja, super cool.
Er hat noch andere Vorträge gehalten?
Dann mache ich das nochmal weiter.
Ich habe ja heute noch einen zweiten Vortrag gehalten zum Thema Datenunterricht.
Ich unterrichte neben Minecraft in der Schule auch noch ein weiteres Fach, nennt sich DAO-Datenunterricht.
Ist eine abgewandelte Form des Informatikunterrichts, aber ich möchte es explizit unterscheiden,
da es tatsächlich wirklich um Daten geht.
Über diesen habe ich berichtet, wie der stattfindet, was die Form ist, welche Ergebnisse ich in den letzten 5, 6 Jahren da herausgenommen habe.
Und so die wichtigsten Erkenntnisse sind auf jeden Fall, dass man diese Form des Unterrichts, dafür brauchen wir keine technischen Mittel.
Also dieser Unterricht findet auch statt ohne irgendeinen Computer.
Ist das eher jetzt quasi nicht Informatikunterricht, wie ich lerne mit Computern umzugehen und zu programmieren,
sondern ich lerne quasi bewusst mit Daten umzugehen, so ein bisschen Medienkompetenz?
Ganz genau. Also es ist stark konzentriert auf das Thema Medienkompetenz und das kritische Hinterfragen von Technik.
Also ich habe immer so eine Leitfrage, die ich diesem Unterricht komplett voran stelle und zwar, was sind meine Daten?
Und diese Frage geht es immer wieder. Auf die versuche ich auch immer wieder zurückzukommen unter den verschiedensten Aspekten.
Vielleicht ein ganz wichtiger Bestandteil, weil ich das gerade auch schon so erwähnt habe,
dass unsere Kinder und Jugendliche ganz schön hilflos sind mit ihren ganzen Alltagstechnikfragen,
die die ältere Generation definitiv gar nicht beantworten kann.
Ein guter Teil des Unterrichts, also fast ein Drittel, besteht daraus, dass sie berichten von ihren Alltagsproblemen.
Da geht es wirklich darum, mein Adblock geht nicht, mein Steam-Account ist gehackt worden, sind die Russen wirklich so gut im Hacken?
Also wirklich all die Dinge, die sie einfach beschäftigen.
Oder die neue App sagt, da ist kein Platz mehr auf der SD-Karte, aber da ist doch Platz drauf.
Da bin ich dann eben sozusagen genau diese Alltagsfragen nehme ich auf und dann sozusagen schauen, die klassischeren Informatik-Themen reinzubringen.
bei der SD-Karte eben dann mal kurz was zu erklären zu Datenträgern, Dateisystemen,
zum Papierkorb, zu versteckten Dateien und so weiter.
Also ich versuche aus den wirklich gängigen Problemen, die sie haben,
dann heraus sozusagen zu filtern und daraus die klassischen Themen abzuleiten.
Aber zentrale Themen sind tatsächlich, was sind meine Daten,
erstmal herausfinden, was ist das Gürtel überhaupt mir und so,
damit ich dann überhaupt weiß, was ich dann schützen muss.
Und natürlich geht es auch um Datenschutz, Datensicherheit,
wie bewege ich mich im Netz, wie recherchere ich im Netz.
Also es gibt schon klassische Informatik-Themen auch,
Aber sozusagen schon ganz zentral immer fokussiert darauf zu sagen,
also darum geht es mal herauszufinden, was sind eigentlich meine Daten, die ich behandeln möchte.
Wie geht das? Hast du einfach die Freiheit, den Unterricht selber zu gestalten?
Mir stellt sich ja gerade die Frage, das klingt super toll, bist du damit alleine?
Machen das andere Lehrer an anderen Schulen auch?
Oder hat das nur das Kind als Vorteil, wenn es wirklich an deine Schule geht?
Momentan, sobald ich das weiß, bin ich die einzige Schule, die diese Form des Unterrichts anbietet.
Ich denke auch von der Tatsache, dass es eine freie Schule ist, wo auch die Elternschaft
ein sehr, sehr hohes Mitspracherecht hat am Gestalten des pädagogischen Programms.
Und so kam ich auf die Idee, über fünf, sechs Jahre habe ich gesagt, das, was jetzt hier
in so einer Informatik stattfindet, finde ich zu wenig.
Ich muss was anderes hin.
Ich habe dann gesagt, liebe Pädagogen und so weiter, hier, ich mache das mal.
Ich bin selbst Vereinsmitglied, meine beiden Kinder gehen auch auf die Schule.
Von daher war ich da eh ganz nah dran und da habe ich einfach angefangen.
Und am Anfang war das noch ein Werkstattzyklus, wo die Schülerinnen sich freiwillig dazu
entscheiden konnten, bei mir zu sein. Konnten aber auch wählen zu klöppeln oder
Holzhacken oder sowas. Und mittlerweile ist es in der Klasse Stufe 7 und 8 sozusagen
normaler Unterricht geworden. Und da habe ich jetzt auch diejenigen dabei, die
eigentlich sich nicht freiwillig für mich entschieden hätten. Und das ist eine sehr
schöne Herausforderung, da jetzt auch nochmal weiter zu arbeiten. Ganz klar ist,
es ist ein Experimentierfeld und ich möchte alle da draußen an den
Empfangsgeräten wirklich anregen. Probiert das bitte aus.
Testet es aus, weil ich habe auch nur meinen Tunnelblick. Ich gebe mir Mühe,
das immer wieder weit aufzuspannen, aber natürlich, ich bin in einem speziellen Umfeld, wo ich sehr viel kann, wo ich sehr viel darf,
wo ich vor allem auch das Vertrauen der Eltern und der Pädagoginnen habe, mit ihren Kindern derartige Dinge zu tun,
das kann an der Regelschule so erstmal nicht stattfinden, das weiß ich ganz genau.
Da gibt es auch immer wieder Nachfragen, wenn andere Pädagoginnen aus der normalen Schule mich fragen,
naja, schön und gut, da klappt das, aber was mache ich denn jetzt hier?
Gibt es auch die Möglichkeiten, dass man das irgendwie verbreitet?
Grundsätzlich sozusagen, die einfachste Möglichkeit wäre natürlich Projekttag oder sowas.
Darüber erstmal sozusagen Low Level, sozusagen irgendwie 1, 2, 3 Tage irgendwie sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen.
Einfach sich mal irgendwie mal sozusagen jetzt Intel und Minecraft oder auch wirklich diesen Datenunterricht einfach mal auszutesten,
sich spezielle Themen zu nehmen und in diesem Format wirklich auch zu unterrichten.
Nackt war das ja erzählt, dass du auch bei Chaos macht Schule mitgemacht hast.
Ist das irgendwie auch im Feld, was Chaos macht Schule beackert?
Nicht direkt.
Also, Klaus macht Schule, also wir bekommen halt Anfragen von Schulen, so im Sinne, yo, könnt ihr einen Vortrag darüber oder darüber halten?
Also das ist schon wirklich spezieller.
Ja, wir halten ja ein solches kein Unterricht, wir machen ja Vorträge oder Workshops, je nachdem.
Wir haben das auch schon mit jüngeren Altersgruppen gemacht, wir haben das jetzt, Mandy hat auch mal Vorlehrungsstudenten gemacht oder Studierenden so.
Aber das ist halt nur punktuell und nicht so allumfassend wie Sandros Datenunterricht.
Von daher ist es, wie gesagt, das war das, was ich am Anfang meinte.
CMS ist schön, es ist ein sehr wichtiges, ein gutes Projekt.
Aber es geht meiner Meinung nach in einigen Punkten nicht weit genug.
Aber das kann man dem Projekt nicht vorwerfen.
Es ist halt ein ehrenamtliches Projekt.
Das sind einfach andere Punkte, wo man ansetzen muss.
Also das geht ja schon in der Ausbildung der Lehrkräfte und Pädagogen los,
dass die einfach Medienkompetenz und Medienpädagogik kennenlernen müssen.
Und das ist aber, soweit ich das weiß, in keinem Bundesland verpflichtender Bestandteil des Studiums,
weder in der Sozialpädagogik noch im Lehramtsstudiengang.
Und da versuchen wir natürlich eine Lücke zu füllen,
die von politischer Seite einfach gerade noch nicht quasi gefordert wird,
in dem Maße, dass es tatsächlich ankommt.
Das ist halt also eine Grassroots-Bewegung.
Ja, also was mir zum Beispiel noch abschließend vielleicht auch ganz wichtig wäre zu erwähnen,
ist, letztes Jahr gab es zum Beispiel von der Frau Johanna Wanker diesen Bildungspakt,
so Digitalisierung, Geld für die Schulen, damit die jetzt die Laptops kaufen können und sowas,
wo ich mir denke, das ist toll, dass ihr da irgendwie Geld bereitstellen wollt,
abgesehen davon, dass das Ländersache ist und so.
Ja, das ist nicht so nach der Wahl.
Dass das politisch extrem schwierig ist aufgrund unseres föderalen Systems oder so.
Aber das ist halt nicht alles.
Also wir müssen halt auch einfach mal ein bisschen in Bildung stecken,
im Sinne von Lehrerbildung beispielsweise oder halt im Ausbau des Studiums.
Das ist halt wichtig, aber genauso halt auch in die Erzieherklassen.
Ich war selber in einer Erzieherausbildung.
Das ist eine Katastrophe, da gibt es keine Medienbildung.
Das heißt, es müssen Leute, die bereits Wissen mitbringen und Erfahrungen mitbringen,
dann selber vor Ort.
Nicht nur Wissenschaftler.
Also meine absolute Hochachtung vor Leuten, die in der Uni arbeiten,
gute Forschungsarbeit leisten. Das ist super wichtig. Aber bitte ladet halt auch solche Leute wie Sandro oder
beispielsweise mich oder das Chaos macht Schule Team oder andere Leute ein, die einfach nochmal einen ganz
anderen Blick darauf haben. Das muss nicht immer zielgerichtet sein. Das muss nicht immer genau das Thema sein.
Aber das bringt einen neuen Wind rein. Da möchte ich auch nochmal ganz klar wirklich betonen. Also was nützen
uns irgendwie 10.000 von Laptops, die irgendwie über Jugendlichen ausgeschüttet werden, wenn niemand in der
Lage ist, ihnen zu sagen, wie sie damit umgehen sollen. Also in der Regel sind die Jugendlichen
sowieso besser, damit umzugehen als die Pädagoginnen. Was wir brauchen, ist tatsächlich gut geschultes
Personal. Und da fängt es ja schon an zu sagen, dazu müssen überhaupt Kapazitäten frei sein.
Wir wissen, wie der aktuelle Schülerinnen-Schnitt ist. Natürlich sind Pädagogen völlig überfordert,
mit derartig vielen Menschen umzugehen, geschweige denn, dass sie danach noch Lust hätten, weitere
Konzepte zu entwickeln. Man kann das Phänomen nur beobachten. Immer wenn sie frisch aus dem Studium
kommen, fünf bis zehn Jahre lang sind sie hochmotiviert, bauen irgendwie Netzwerke auf, haben Ideen,
machen Projekttage und Wochen und hin und her.
Und irgendwann können sie einfach nicht mehr.
Wir haben da wirklich ein strukturelles Problem.
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die haben super Ideen,
machen feine Dinge und diese müssen unterstützt werden.
Die müssen von oben unterstützt werden,
damit das wirklich auch auf andere ansteckend wirken kann.
Und so sehen alle anderen nur,
die brennt eh aus in den nächsten zwei Jahren.
Ja, toll.
Da fehlt ganz klar der Wille von oben zu sagen,
okay, wir halten es für gut und richtig,
dass innovative Ideen, auch mal ein bisschen skurrile Sachen,
einfach mal ausgetestet werden.
Weil wenn wir das nicht austesten, wir verlieren den Anschluss.
wir kriegen. Das ist, was ich am Anfang schon meinte.
Ich bin auch nur da, ich bin eigentlich
nur dabei, weil ich sozusagen hilflos
bin, weil ich eigentlich nicht wirklich weiß, was ich sozusagen
tun soll. Da will ich wenigstens dabei sein
sozusagen auf diesem sinken Schiff.
Da will ich wenigstens sagen, okay, ich war dabei, ich habe noch
die beste Stimmung gemacht, ich habe noch die Basketballe
gespielt, weißt du? Also wir müssen
wenigstens dabei sein, um dann auch zu wissen,
es könnte dies oder jenes sein, wo es daneben steht
und zugucken. Das ist eindeutig falsch.
Also wir brauchen Bildung für Pädagoginnen.
Das ist ein Wahnsinnsappell.
Wir nähern uns auch jetzt langsam dem Ende unseres selbst gesteckten Zeitrahmens hier.
Jetzt zum Schluss, das war ja quasi schon in einer Reihe, aber was möchtet ihr jetzt damit transportieren?
Wenn Leute jetzt diese Sendung und diese Aufzeichnung hören, die vielleicht Lehrämter sind oder die vielleicht Eltern sind oder was für eine Botschaft wollt ihr an Leute, die vielleicht nicht Politiker selber sind?
das war ja gerade ein Aufruf an Politiker, weitergeben.
Ich glaube Sandro und er hat mich mittlerweile auch davon überzeugt,
du sagt immer: Hab Mut, was Neues zu versuchen.
Das kam halt auch bei Mandys Talk durch, bei den Projektideen.
Es gibt halt auch kleine Sachen, ihr müsst nicht gleich einen Programmierkurs anbieten,
ihr könnt auch irgendwas Kleines machen.
So, keine Ahnung, gib mal kurz ein Beispiel.
Du hast so tolle Ideen gehabt, Gisela.
Ja, einfach mal die Kinder mit der Kamera durch die Schule schicken und die Lieblingsorte fotografieren lassen zum Beispiel und dann zusammentragen, Fotos abändern, gucken, was Effekte mit den Fotos machen. Ganz kleine Sachen.
So Hands-on-Geschichten.
Also man muss nicht gleich riesig in das Thema einsteigen, man kann es einfach langsam machen. Und ansonsten, eure Menschen, völlige Schülerinnen, Lehrerinnen, Eltern sind, spielt keine Rolle, holt sie da ab, wo sie sind und nicht da, wo sie hin sollen oder irgendwas anderes.
Was mir auch ganz wichtig ist, ist einfach keine Angst zu haben, das okay zu finden, dass ich das vielleicht nicht alles weiß.
Ich weiß vielleicht nicht, was Instagram ist oder was man damit macht.
Und einfach Fragen, die dies benutzen und sich zeigen lassen von den eigenen Schülerinnen, von der Mama, wer auch immer das halt gerade benutzt.
Und lernen mit den anderen, sich gegenseitig was geben, nicht nur belehren.
Das ist allgemein so eine große Schrankarbeittechnik, dass man sich immer nicht traut zu fragen und zuzugestehen, dass man es nicht weiß oder nicht versteht.
Man denkt, die anderen gerade im Hacker-Umfeld, für diesen ist das alles so einfach aus,
da bin ich bestimmt der Einzige, der so blöd ist.
Das ist auch so ein Verständnis, was wichtig ist, auch bei Lehrern zu transportieren.
Stellt mal Fragen zu Sachen, das ist vollkommen okay.
Ja, das ist mir glaube ich, über das Thema wirklich auch Mut zu machen.
Zu dem Thema Datenunterricht und Bildung, wie es mit Pädagoginnen habe ich ja schon einiges
gesagt, zum Thema Spielen sozusagen, was auch gerade ein gesellschaftlich sehr relevantes
Thema ist, würde ich auch noch ganz klar sagen: Liebe Eltern, bitte spielen!
Spielt mit euren Kindern.
Sagt ihnen nur einfach, hör auf zu zocken, komm zum Abendbrot,
sondern setzt euch hin und lasst euch mitreißen.
Versucht euch in die Welt hineinzudenken und dort einfach dabei zu sein.
Auch wenn ihr erst mal nichts versteht von dem, was auf diesem Monitor passiert.
Bleibt dabei und beobachtet eure Kinder.
Schaut sie euch an, was es mit ihnen tut.
Es kann ganz schnell sein, dass ihr sagt, das sollte jetzt wirklich nicht weiterspielen.
Dann ist das richtig.
Aber es kann auch sein, dass ihr sagt, kann ich mal bitte auch an die Tastatur.
Und das erlebe ich in der Praxis ganz, ganz häufig.
Also ganz dringend, immer nach außen zu gucken und zu sagen, was ihr macht, ist falsch oder blöd.
Ich verstehe es nicht. Das ist falsch. Liebe Eltern, bitte spielt mit euren Kindern.
Das sind wunderschöne letzte Worte. Vielen Dank. Also spielt mehr.
Das war ein Interview von Akonomisierbar mit Sandro, Nack und Mandy.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr euch Zeit genommen habt, um mit uns zu reden.
Und noch schöne Datenspuren. Danke sehr.
Danke an euch.
Tschüss.
Also wir haben, ja Soundcloud, wir haben sogar ein Jahresabbau abgeschlossen.
Bei Soundcloud, die gerade ein bisschen am Arsch sind.
Wollte nicht vielleicht noch ein zweites oder ein drittes abschließen?
Vielleicht halten sie dann ja.
Aber Hendrik fehlt.
Der ist gerade rausgegangen.
Hallo.
Das ist doch wieder da.
Du hast Notizen, da will ich auch Notizen mitführen.
Ich habe mir bloß gerade in deinem Talk ein bisschen was mitgeschnitten, äh geschrieben.
Also wir sitzen jetzt hier nochmal mit Axel am zweiten Tag der Datenspuren.
Du hast nämlich zweierlei Beiträge dieses Mal geleistet. Du bist richtig fleißig.
Ja, es war richtig viel. Ich bin richtig müde.
Du hast gerade einen Vortrag über Speck gehalten. Was ist denn das?
Speck ist ein Paketmanager. Und zwar speziell kam der aus der Welt des High-Performance-Computings.
Und worauf der sich spezialisiert hat, ist von Source möglichst viele Konfigurationen gleichzeitig von bestehenden Software zu bauen.
so dass man als Entwickler gegen viele Sachen durchtesten kann.
Das heißt, das ist so eine Art Paketmanager,
wie ich mir das vorstellen kann,
wie dieser Debian-Paketmanager zum Anwendungen installieren?
Im Kleinen Debian-Paketmanager ist tatsächlich ganz anders.
Der Ansatz ist natürlich ähnlich.
Du möchtest Software bekommen.
Und gerade für Distributionen wie Debian ist meistens das Ziel,
du versuchst jetzt einen konsistenten State,
also einen konsistenten Eindruck,
deine Software zu bekommen in einem System.
und dabei brauchst du das immer mit der gleichen Toolchain,
also zum Beispiel dem gleichen Compiler, gegen die gleichen Libraries
und mit den gleichen Flags, die man dann geben kann.
Ist nicht der Hauptunterschied, dass ich bei so einer Linux-Distribution
bei den Paketmanager bereits fertig gebaut habe,
eine Software hole?
Das ist noch ein extra Part.
Die können aber grundsätzlich dir auch die Rezepte mitliefern.
Also zum Beispiel der DB-Paketmanager kann dir auch die Source-Codes liefern
und dich das selbst bauen lassen.
Das kann Speck grundsätzlich auch, seit Neuesten tatsächlich.
als Binary Cache einfach, aber in der Regel
baut man einfach von so aus seine ganze Toolchain.
Und ja, eigentlich ist das
motiviert gewesen aus der Not, dass die
das entwickelt hatten. Und zwar
ist das eine Weiterentwicklung von bestehenden
Automatisierungslösungen. Also die Not,
die man oft hatte als Entwickler oder
speziell jetzt auf System, die
bei uns jetzt im HPC-Bereich ist es so,
du bekommst die einmal geliefert bei dem
Hersteller und ganz oft werden die dann zertifiziert.
Und dann bekommt man zum Beispiel ein
erstaltes Red Hat und
dazu GCC45.
und dann versucht man damit seine C++14-Software draufzubauen.
Was natürlich absolut nicht geht.
Was absolut nicht geht, genau.
Und da ist die Not draus geboren worden,
dass das meistens schief geht,
nicht nur weil die Software zu alt ist,
aber auch wenn man zum Beispiel versucht,
Teile vom System zu nehmen und Teile nachzubauen.
Das geht einem auch oft schief.
Weil in den ganzen Linux-Distributionen
bereits irgendwelche Standardbibliotheken mitgegeben werden.
Genau, also Standardbibliotheken sind schon das Problem,
die dann einfach, die ABI ist inkompatibel schon allein davon.
Weil es mit einem anderen Compiler gebaut wurde.
Genau, selbst mit dem gleichen Compiler,
mit einer älteren Version ist schon ein Problem.
Und es sind ein Haufen
einfach Probleme dazukommen in letzter Zeit,
dadurch, dass die Sprachen glücklicherweise weiterentwickeln.
Also bei C++ zum Beispiel,
der Wechsel von C++ 98
zu 11 hat zum Beispiel nochmal
einige Änderungen gemacht, auch in Standardbibliotheken,
dass zum Beispiel, was immer gebraucht wird,
ein Standard-String zum Beispiel, der ist auf einmal anders implementiert
und hat auch ein anderes Interface
dazu und in dem Moment kommen auf einmal
die Probleme nicht nur, du kannst den gleichen
Compiler haben, du kannst
vielleicht sogar die gleiche Version haben, aber wenn du eine andere
nur genommen hast, zum Beispiel welche Standardversion.
In dem Moment hast du dann wieder dein Problem bekommen
und dadurch kam so die Idee auf, vielleicht
muss ich meine Abhängigkeiten und die Konfiguration,
die ich für Softwarebauer besser beschreiben kann.
Und das müsste jetzt
Speck damit lösen, dass es quasi dir
ermöglicht, nicht die
vom System mitgegebenen Sachen
benutzen zu müssen, sondern dass du alles
wohlbeschrieben, vom Compiler
über Flex, über welche
Version vom Source nehme ich, dass du das
alles in deinem Bildsystem beschreiben kannst?
Genau, also
Wo Speck meistens von anfängt, ist mit einem Compiler.
Man kann sich den auch selber erst mal bauen mit Speck,
wenn man das möchte.
Das muss man ja, wenn man nicht auf die alte Version
auf diesem Uraltwert angewiesen sein muss.
Exakt, genau. Dann muss man das.
Man kann sich aber auch einfach einen Binär-Plop
von dem Compiler runterladen und mit dem arbeiten.
Man kann immer noch rückfallen auf System-Libraries,
wenn man die nicht bauen möchte.
Aber man kann grundsätzlich einfach von der Pike aufwärts alles bauen.
Und wo zieht Speck die Dinge her?
Das ist das Schöne.
Die Repositories sind sozusagen eigentlich nur
eine Sammlung von Bauanleitungen.
Also der Bauanleitung steht drin, wo bekomme ich die Software her? Brauche ich bei gewissen Abhängigkeiten von Nice-Drucker-Patches? Was dann auch irgendwie ganz nett ist, wenn man das konoperativ bei irgendwie den Patch für Sanores irgendwie noch einpflegen kann. Und danach sagt man einfach nur, okay, ich hänge davon ab und dann baut man die nacheinander durch.
Das heißt, die Quellen beschreibe ich jetzt nicht mit, das ist jetzt zum Beispiel libpng-Version 1, 2, 3, sondern ich möchte libpng und das liegt auf github-axl-libpng oder sowas?
Genau, also man kann, normalerweise macht man ein Paket mit einer Quelle und da ist es dann, kriegt man alle Versionen her und die kann man da einfach listen.
Und das wird einfach über RegExus an der Stelle gemacht.
Gibt es da irgendwie eine zentrale Registry?
Genau, also Specs selber hat ein Build-In-Repo und da drin sind einfach immer kurze kleine Python-Klassen, also das ist in Python geschrieben, in denen Quelle, Versionen, die geprüft wurden von Leuten, die es einfach gecheckt haben und dann einfach mal eine Hecht dazugelegt haben und Abhängigkeitsbeschreibung drin. Man kann aber auch ohne Probleme einfach lokal sich eigene Pakete dazubauen oder eigene Repos dazubauen.
Das heißt, die Registry, was jetzt bei sowas wie NPM oder sowas eine große Datenbank ist, ist bei Spec ein einzelnes Git-Repository, wo das alles drin steht?
Also genau, in dem Haupt-Git-Repository gibt es einen Build-In-Ordner. In dem ist das Build-In-Repo drin. Das kann man aber einfach ignorieren oder überschreiben. Und das ist über normale YAML-Config-Files konfigurierbar.
Bei anderen Pakete kann ich da auch irgendwie reinschieben. Ich meine, du hast vorhin gezeigt in deinen Folien, du hast einfach spec install, ein Paketname einnehmen, das muss ja irgendwo dann in diesem bereit liegen, in diesem Repository oder dieser Registry, wie auch immer man das bezeichnen möchte dann.
I don't digit identifizieren.
Genau, also die Repositories zur Zeit sind nicht wie bei Debian oder bei anderen Paketmanagern oder bei NPM einfach nur online, wo du sie reinschieben musst, sondern wie das funktioniert ist, genauso wie der Install zur Zeit, du machst einfach ein Git-Klon von dem ganzen Repository und im Moment gehören dir auch die Dateien und du kannst da einfach natürlich dort noch hinzufügen. Alternativ, wenn ein Systemadministrator zum Beispiel für dich das Paket installiert hat, dann kannst du einfach in deinem Home noch neue Paketrepositeurs hinzulegen und dann funktioniert das.
Das ist ein bisschen wie ein Homebook.
Ja, würde ich gerade sagen, das erinnert mich sehr an Homebook.
Genau, sehr ähnlich dazu.
Das ist cool.
Genau, ja.
Eine andere Sache, die mir noch als Frage übrig geblieben ist an dem Talk.
Du hattest erwähnt,
ich gucke, wie formuliere ich das jetzt?
Du hattest erwähnt, dass man diverse Bild-Skripte braucht
im Anfangteil deines Talks auf alte Sachen wie Make,
beziehungsweise nicht kasselte, aber immer noch aktuelle Sachen wie Make und C-Make eingegangen.
Wie ist es denn bei, sagen wir mal, sehr modernen Sprachen,
wie zum Beispiel Rust oder das PIP-Enf, wenn du das kennst,
mit Python da jetzt versucht, dass ein bisschen von diesen Manifestdateien weggeht,
aber gerade was diese formatischen Manifestdateien eben angeht,
wo quasi auch alles schon beschrieben mit drin ist,
meine ganzen Dependencies beschrieben sind mit Versionen
und möglicherweise irgendwelchen Ranges von Versionen und anderen Schritten,
die ich noch brauche, um das zu bauen.
Rust fällt mir jetzt diese Bilder erst ein, wo ich noch beliebigen Kram mit reinpacken kann,
den ich brauche, um das Paket zu konfigurieren.
Löst das nicht ein ähnliches Problem an der Stelle?
Ist das nicht auch möglich darüber, das alles zu handhaben, ohne da jetzt noch einen Packetmanager komplett drüber zu legen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich studiere am besten über PIP und über die Python-Welt, da kenne ich mich ein bisschen mehr aus als über die Last-Welt.
Da ist selbstverständlich ein gewisses Satz an Duplizität gerade in der Beschreibung drin und ich will es mal versuchen aufzudröseln.
Was ein Paketmanager macht, ist, der versucht von den lokalen Software, die vorliegt, oder mit Tricks, wie er es nachinstallieren kann.
Das ist mittlerweile experimentell immer mal möglich. Versucht er aufzulösen, welche Version von den vielen Varianten, die es da gibt, möchte ich nutzen, abhängig von den Anforderungen, die ich zum Beispiel in ein CMake-File oder in ein Setup-Pie geschrieben habe.
Zum einen findet er die und zum anderen übersetzt er die in, und das ist die Abstraktion, die ein Buildmanager bringt, übersetzt er die in die jeweils spezifischen, zum Beispiel, wie macht der Compiler dann Linken, wie wird der Compiler gewisse Warnings an- und ausschalten, wie kann er gewisse Debugflakes setzen und deutlich auch kompliziertere Sachen, zum Beispiel Unterscheidung von System- und Nicht-System-Libraries, da kann man auch noch beliebig rumspielen.
Das geht auch noch weiter dann zum Architektur zum Beispiel, also wie wird das in dem Dena angesprochen.
Was ein Paketmanager braucht oder was er liefert obendrauf dazu ist, der providet die Software.
Also der zum Beispiel, in dem beschreibt man, okay, ich brauche mindestens die Software und wenn mein Bildsystem akzeptiert, ich kann mit meinetwegen LibPNG Version 1.4 oder Neue bauen, dann wird der Paketmanager entscheiden, was er davon anbietet.
Und sozusagen als Nutzer möchte ich sozusagen eigentlich immer auf dem hohen Level von einem Paketmanager sprechen, dass ich sage, okay, zeig mir mal, wie die Software aussieht, wenn ich die mit einer anderen Abhängigkeit baue oder baue sie mir nochmal mit einer anderen Abhängigkeit, um zu sehen, ob die überhaupt damit funktioniert. Wohingegen das Bildsystem in der Regel einfach akzeptiert, was es bekommt, solange es die Minimalanforderungen hat. Und der Paketmanager macht sozusagen das Makroskopische rundherum.
Okay.
Du hattest ja diesen Use Case beschrieben, dass man sagen kann,
baue mir mal meine Library, die von libpng abhängt und libpng hängt ab von zlib.
Und jetzt probiere mal genau das zu bauen, aber nimm eine andere Version von zlib,
was ja bereits eine transitive Abhängigkeit ist.
Genau, das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Also was man vielleicht ganz oft kennt, wenn man mit systeminstallierten Paketmanagern arbeitet,
ist, wenn ich eine andere Version brauche, dann ist es meistens im Namen encoded.
Also ich mache sowas wie UpsGetInstall und dann G++ oder G++-4.9, weil ich nochmal eine alte Version davon benutzen möchte.
Wenn man in diesen Lib-Ordner in seiner Linux-Distribution reinschaut, dann sieht man ja meistens, dass hinten an dem Namen irgendwie doch diese Version dranhängen.
Es sind dann irgendwie Softlinks auf die andere.
Exakt, das ist ein großer Berg von Softlinks und da gibt es dann auch wieder Tools, die für dich die Softlinks umsetzen.
Das Update-Alternatives ist so ein gutes Beispiel in der Debian-Welt.
Das ist natürlich insoweit ein bisschen ärgerlich, wenn es feinkranulare wird, weil man muss natürlich eine ganze Menge Suffixe dort anfügen auf einmal. Und deine Frage war jetzt, wenn ich eine andere Zlib-Werson installieren möchte, was Spec da macht und was ist eben das Konzept dann erstellt, das haben auch andere Paketmanager mittlerweile gesehen und bauen das auch ein, ist die ergebende Möglichkeit, die transitiven Dependencies einfach als Syntax auszudrücken.
Also in dem Fall ist das so.
Wir gehen mal in die Python-Welt zurück.
Da gibt es pip install und dann Python-Paket.
Und bei specware hat das spec install Paket.
Also spec install, sagen wir mal, PNG-Writer,
was irgendein C++-Projekt ist, was libpng braucht.
Wenn ich jetzt aber weiß, dass PNG-Writer abhängt von libpng
oder von zlib, dann habe ich die Möglichkeit,
einfach auf der Kommandozeile in dieser Syntax,
die dieser Install-Befehl ist, einfach das auszudrücken.
Und zwar macht man dann einfach ein, ja,
Accent surcum flex.
Ein Dach.
Da mache ich einfach Leerzeichen Dach.
Heute Französisch für Anfänger.
In einer sehr starken Aussprache.
Danke.
Genau, und da macht man einfach
sozusagen dieses Dach
und schreibt dann die Abhängigkeit hin.
Und genauso wie wenn man nur die Abhängigkeit direkt installieren würde,
kann man also schreiben, meinetwegen
PNG-Writer, dann Dach-Lib-PNG
und dann Add-Version.
Oder ich mache sogar eine
transitive Abhängigkeit, die ich nicht direkt habe.
Da mache ich also Dach Z-Lib und gebe da dann die Version an
oder gebe an der wieder eine Variante an, zum Beispiel Z-Lib, aber im Debug-Modus.
Gibt es da Leute, die das bereits irgendwie in der CI testen?
Das klingt ja, als ob das super geeignet wäre, um zu schauen,
mit welchen Versionen von den Libraries ist denn jetzt meins kompatibel
und wo könnte ich das auf welchen noch so stabilen Debian-Versionen
oder Ubuntu-Versionen ausliefern?
Also wie es der Zufall will, ist mein Beitrag zu Spec,
die Dokumentation genau dieser Workflows.
Ah, sehr cool.
Also ich habe in der Dokumentation den Anteil geschrieben, wie man auf Travis CI Speck nutzen kann,
um einfach verschiedene Boost-Versionen zum Beispiel durchzutesten in C++-Projekten
und genauso, wie man Docker-Container partitionieren kann mit Speck.
Weil auch bei, wenn man so sagen, in die Richtung geht, einfach nochmal richtig von einem bare System anzufangen,
also Virtualisierung oder Docker ins Mittelweg, da ist natürlich auch die Frage,
wie partitioniere ich denn so einen extrem low-level Ubuntu zum Beispiel, auf dem ich jetzt gerade testen möchte.
Und da bietet sich ein Paketmanager auch an, der nochmal richtig von scratch sich die Daten runterziehen kann.
Und ja, genau die zwei Sachen habe ich beigetragen und die stehen dort im Read the Docs.
Nice.
Also Read the Docs, das deutet auch darauf hin, Spec ist in Python geschrieben, ja?
Ja, tatsächlich. Das fand ich am Anfang auch relativ lustig, weil ich dachte so, okay, Python ist jetzt auch nicht die geringsten Abhängigkeiten selber.
Aber tatsächlich, solange man einen Python-Interpreter mindestens 2.7 zur Verfügung hat und der funktioniert, kann man danach losgehen.
und es hat natürlich selber auch noch ein paar Abhängigkeiten,
aber als Paketmanager hat es den schönen Befehl Bootstrap
und dann baut sich seine eigenen Abhängigkeiten.
Ansonsten wäre es wahrscheinlich die perfekte Folge,
um eigentlich Jörg dabei zu haben und ein bisschen über Nix zu nerden.
Das haben wir vorhin in der Fragerunde von deinem Talk
mal kurz mit angesprochen.
Nix ist ja auch so ein cooles Projekt,
was sehr ähnlich versucht, Dinge zu lösen,
beziehungsweise einmal Nix US als Betriebssystem,
was komplett alles mit reinpackt,
oder Nix einfach nur als Paketmanager,
der versucht, genau ähnlich wie die Spectre, das heranzugehen und Dinge sehr abgekapselt voneinander zu handhaben
und vor allem Pakete in verschiedenen Versionen lokal installieren zu lassen.
Die kannst du in diesen Nix-Store reinpacken und kannst da einfach deine Reihenlinkung auf aktuelle Version
oder zu aktuell verwenden müssen, benutzen.
Auf jeden Fall müssen wir da nochmal drüber reden in der späteren Folge.
Wir sind ja allgemein für beide auch bereits sehr interessiert an Paketmanagement.
Wir haben ja auch in vorherigen Folgen schon mal drüber geredet.
Ich fand, dass bei deinem Vortrag, ist der eigentlich aufgezeichnet worden, sag mal?
Ich glaube schon.
letztes jahr hatte die hefte keinen ton auf dies jahr ist besser also schaut euch unbedingt
schaut euch unbedingt auf der webseite der datenspuren die aufzeichnung von axels talk
an was ich richtig schön fand war diese taxonomie die zur einordnung von paketmanagern da gebracht
dass ich weiß nicht ob du die auch her dass du hast unterschiedliche sachen unterschieden die
an denen sich wahrscheinlich und den sich paketmanagern relativ gut unterscheiden lassen
zum einen wo installiert pakete hin ist es auch wie fix path oder ist das ein flexibel flexibel
kannst du unterstützen zu mehrere unterschiedliche Versionen parallel von unterschiedlichen Abhängigkeiten,
wie wird es contained, wie wird es geshippt, ist es configuration aware und ist es multi-language aware.
Das finde ich ziemlich spannend, weil wenn du diese Fragen nämlich stellst an zum Beispiel NPM oder sowas,
dann fallen ja einige Sachen raus.
Ich meine, NPM nutzen Leute auch, um irgendwelche CSS-Sachen so auszuliefern.
Aber eigentlich sind wir eine Sprache.
Also genau, was mir auch ganz wichtig ist an der Stelle,
war eigentlich die Konzepte in dem Vortrag rüberzubringen,
die mir aufgefallen sind in meiner täglichen Arbeit.
Das ist eigentlich die Frage, die man sich am Anfang stellen sollte.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Projekt habe und ich habe gewisse Zielanforderungen,
also ich möchte zum Beispiel eine Verbindung schaffen
zwischen der JavaScript-Welt und der C-Welt oder C++-Welt
oder Python und der C-Welt oder ich habe ein ganz reines JavaScript-Projekt,
dann fallen ganz andere Lösungen raus.
Und wenn man nach der Liste einfach durchgeht, die ich gezeigt habe,
man gibt sich dann schon relativ schnell,
welche Paketmänner das können und welche das nicht.
Kannst du mir den Punkt Containment mal erklären?
Da hast du einen Unterschied zwischen We-Containment with Environment oder Fully Virtual.
Genau.
Was bedeutet das?
Also grundsätzlich sind das natürlich keine festen Begriffe,
sondern die habe ich mir einfach aus Erfahrung und Schmerzen,
die mir aufgefallen sind, irgendwie ausgedacht, die mir da orthogonal erschienen.
Was heißt denn Containment erstmal?
Containment erstmal grundsätzlich, wie das virtualisiert oder beziehungsweise
in welcher Art und Weise du das einhausen kannst, deine Software, die du einbaust.
Also interagiert die stark mit dem System, in dem es lebt, oder ist die komplett unabhängig davon?
Also da würde man jetzt so etwas sagen wie, der Debian-Paketmanager interagiert sehr stark mit dem System, weil er es direkt verändert.
Genau, weil er die Systemfahle ändert.
Und sowas wie NPM, das legt für alles eine redundante Kopie in einen NPM-Node-Modules-Ordner daneben.
Dementsprechend ist es fully virtual.
Ne, das würde ich als Week-In-Wine-Main-Beschreiben, weil in dem Moment, du interagierst immer noch mit deinem Kostsystem.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du als Paketentwickler vergisst, eine Abhängigkeit zu beschreiben, dann wird er versehentlich gegen dein Host-System liegen.
Dann sucht er sie im System.
Genau.
Und aber die Steuerung, wann es aktiv wird, machst du einfach über Umgebungsvariablen zum Beispiel oder irgendwelche Aktivierungen.
Wohingegen Full-E-Virtual ist dann eine Sache, die eigentlich keine Paketmanager mehr sind, aber die können wir theoretisch in den Paketmanager reinbauen.
Ist zum Beispiel wirklich dann einen Docker-Container oder eine VM hochzustarten und nur das in der drin zu haben.
Wenn du es komplett abgeschottet hast.
Die nicht-virtuelle Variante
davon wahrscheinlich wirklich nichts
zu essen.
Genau, das ist der Punkt.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, noch einen mehr sogar.
Das war dann, ob die selber mitbekommen, ob die updatetbar
sind oder nicht. Das war bei
Ubuntu haben die RET4 experimentiert mit
Snap-Paketen. Und zumindest aus
meiner schwachen Erfahrung, die ich da aus Literaturrecherchen
bekommen habe, ist das
coole gewesen, dass die eben auch sehr contained
waren. Also das Paket selber hat all seine Abhängigkeiten
und versucht abgeschottet zu sein und auch
einen gewissen Sicherheitsaspekt mitzubringen.
Und es kriegt selber trotzdem noch mit,
wann es Sicherheitsupdates zum Beispiel bekommt.
Hast du dich mit diesen
Systemen mal ein bisschen genauer auseinandergesetzt?
Weil es gibt ja momentan wieder mal
two competing standards.
Es gibt diese Snap-Pakete, die Ubuntu entwickelt hat
und es gibt aus der Gnome-Welt diese Flatpack-Pakete.
Hast du dich da mal reingelesen?
Ich habe die tatsächlich reingelesen, aber
ich glaube, ich bin nicht kompetent, das gut zu kommentieren.
Es würde mich auch mal interessieren,
wie die sich unterscheiden. Die scheinen irgendwie das gleiche Problem
lösen zu wollen.
weiter. Aber da ich
weder Gnome noch Ubuntu-Entwickler bin, kann ich das nicht sagen.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass die das ähnlich Problem angehen.
Also ich glaube, da geht es darum, vor allem
komplexe, mit viel Abhängigkeiten Software
zu shippen. Also es geht nicht unbedingt
darum, das als Developer irgendwie leichter zu machen, aber
zum Beispiel in Browser ordentlich zu verpacken.
Und ein gutes Beispiel ist zum Beispiel
bei Debian, warum du dort
nicht über gewisse Firefox-Versionen hinauskommst.
Das liegt einfach daran, weil eine meiner Versionen
von Rust dort drin zu alt ist.
Und da musst du also sozusagen den ganzen
Rattenschwanz über Rust und was das wieder
gescheitend mitbringen, noch mitbringen.
Ich habe neulich einen Kollegen von mir rumgekotzt auf Arbeit, der muss irgendwie unseren Code
auf die neuesten Firefox-Versionen portieren und ist natürlich der Bein-Nutzer.
Und hatte Probleme, sich das neuste Firefox überhaupt zu installieren, weil da ein paar
Abhängigkeiten plötzlich drin waren, die vorher nicht da waren.
Unterscheidet man in deiner Welt eigentlich zwischen Package und Dependency-Managern oder
ist das quasi dann das Gleiche?
Ich würde das Synonym benutzen, aber es gibt bestimmt einen Unterschied.
Also ich habe es bisher immer genutzt, den Unterschied, Dependency-Manager installiere
ich mit Dependencies für mein Tool
aktuell, meistens in der Sprache
oder dem Framework, in dem ich gerade bin.
Und Package Manager ist dann wirklich der systemweit
Ding installiert, aber da gibt es halt wirklich, das ist ein riesiges
Vendor mit einem ganz großen Ding
in der Mitte. Die meisten sind beides.
Die meisten sind wie gesagt in der Mitte dann.
Es ist Speck vorgesehen,
dass man damit sich einfach Pakete
installiert und nur um sie zu benutzen, also
nur um das Endergebnis
zu benutzen oder ist das wirklich vornehmlich
dafür gedacht, dass ich mir Sourcen dafür besorge?
Beides. Du kannst dir
auch direkt die Pakete holen, wenn du einen Binary
Cache hinterlegst. Aber das Interessante, was die noch haben, ist,
was mich immer interessiert, ist, die
Anwendung kann ich als Nutzer die Pakete selber
bauen. Also zum Beispiel ein Upget kann ich nicht
machen, wenn ich nicht root bin auf dem System.
Und was Speck schön mitbringt,
ist die Möglichkeit,
dass du als Systemadministrator eine Speck-Instanz
installierst und dann als
Nutzer die Nutzer-Instanz davon
aware ist von der Version.
Also du kannst als Nutzer dann neue Software hinzuinstallieren,
überschreiben, oder also wenn du jetzt
zum Beispiel sagst, okay, aber ich brauche jetzt die
eine andere Variante, dann baut du sie für dich neu.
Aber dann nutzt die erst. Du kannst direkt damit interagieren
und kannst damit sozusagen als Systemadministrator
schon sehr fein getunte Pakete
vorgeben, zum Beispiel für irgendwelche
Netzwerklibraries, weil du exotische Netzwerkkarten
irgendwie verbaut hast. Und darauf
baut dann die Nutzer einfach aus und muss sich da nicht mehr die Gedanken
darüber machen, wie ihr die nochmal konfiguriert.
Das ist super praktisch. Du hast auch
super Kontrolle über, was in deinem Ökosystem
so installiert ist und welche Software du dir zur Verfügung
stellen möchtest. Exakt.
Du kannst hier natürlich dann auch einbetten oder
was für
für viele kommerzielle oder manchmal auch manche wissenschaftliche Sachen auch anwesentlich ist,
ist, du kannst natürlich auch nicht nur Open Source Software dazu bringen, sondern
unterstützt auch zum Beispiel Lizenzen für kommerzielle Compiler ordentlich mitzubringen
oder auch eben lokale Software, die es wirklich nur lokal gibt, mit der lokalen Bildanweisung dafür.
Das ist jetzt nicht die Welt, in der ich lebe. Ich versuche die Software, die wir bauen,
eigentlich grundsätzlich, weil sie von öffentlichem Geld bezahlt wird, auch grundsätzlich offen
als Ergebnis rauszubekommen. Aber die Anwender gibt es natürlich, oder sobald es irgendwie
sicherheitskritisch wird. Ja, gibt es viele amerikanische Anwendungen, die es mehr brauchen.
Eine Sache, die mich noch irritiert hat, ist, du hattest beschrieben, dass dieses Manifest-Format,
das ist auch noch was, was sich unterscheidet. Es gibt Paketmanager, wo man ein Manifest in
einer Markdown-Sprache hat, sowas wie Tommel oder Jason oder so. Und dann gibt es Sprachen oder
Paketmanager, wo du das in einer ausführbaren Code hast, wie bei Swift oder bei Ruby. Und bei
Bei Spec ist es so, dass das Manifest-Format auch eine einfach Python-Datei ist
und du implementierst eine bestimmte Klasse oder du erbst von einer bestimmten Klasse
und konfigurierst es da drin.
Aber dann hast du auch noch gleichzeitig gesagt, dass es YAML-Beschreibungsdateien
oder Konfigurationsdateien gibt. Wie verhält sich das? Wann benutzt man das?
Also die YAML-Konfigurationsdateien sind, um Specs selbst zu konfigurieren.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man neue Compiler hinzufügen möchte.
Dafür gibt es natürlich immer CLI-Interfaces.
Also mit der Kommandozeile kann man das einfach machen.
aber man kann auch die direkt editieren.
Das heißt, die sind nicht pro Paket?
Nee, die sind pro, also die sind erstmal zum Beispiel,
wenn man sagt, Systemadministrator und Nutzer,
dann gibt es für den Systemadministrator
einen Pfeil dazu und der Nutzer kann das überschreiben.
Genauso wie man das kennt mit seinen Punkt Profile
und Punkt Bash-Acees, da gibt es systemweit eine
und dann kann ich die aber als Nutzer auch nochmal abändern.
Das heißt, das ist dann das, wo du zum Beispiel
deine zentrale Registry eintragen würdest?
Da kann ich eine weitere Registry hinzufügen,
Repos nenne ich das, genau.
Oder ich kann an der Stelle auch die Forks ändern.
Zum Beispiel ist das Back für
HBC, also für Cluster
normalerweise gebaut wird, ist zum Beispiel
der Standard, wenn ein Paket eine Variante
anbietet, die Netzwerkunterstützung mit MPI hat,
dann sagen die, bau das mal grundsätzlich.
Und wenn ich das jetzt aber als Developer auf meinem Desktop
mache, will ich das vielleicht gar nicht. Und so
die Fortkette muss zum Beispiel standardmäßig in einem
YAML-File einmal ändern und dann hat man das Problem
nicht mehr. Also das ist das, was in
NPM-Welt der.npm-rc
unterbrechen würde.
Das Interessante ist auch ein eigenes
Format, die ganzen Package-Jasons sind Jasons
und die EPMRC ist ein zahlenbasiertes
Gewehrjubbar.
Ja, und die Pakete selber, das ist der andere Part,
der ist tatsächlich einfach eine Python-Klasse,
die erbt von ihrem Build-System.
Also zum Beispiel erbt die von Simic
oder erbt von Makefile, falls eins ist,
und kann dann patchen und die Phasen des Bounds
überschreiben.
Und die sind soweit deutlich hackiger als funktionale Ansätze.
Man kommt aber auch sehr schnell
zu dem Ergebnis. Also wenn man sozusagen
harte Hackse an der Stelle braucht und sagt, ich habe die Pansy
mit einem Patch, dann ist das möglich.
Muss man aber nicht. Man kann die auch einfach sehr
benutzt.
Abgefahren. Ziemlich.
War ein cooler Talk, auf jeden Fall.
Danke, danke. Ja, vielen Dank für diese
zusätzlichen Fragen, die wir dir stellen
durften. Bei deinem Talk sind ja leider die
Frage-Antwort ein bisschen kurz ausgefallen
oder komplett ausgefallen.
Wir hatten eine Frage.
Vielen Dank, Axel, dass du noch ein zweites Mal
bei uns warst. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Danke.
Das war unsere Folge AkonomiSieber,
Folge Sonderedition, keine Nummer diesmal.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören auf jeden Fall.
Ihr findet uns online auf
akronymisierbar auf Twitter oder unter
unseren privaten Handels. Die stehen aber auch in der Bio von dem
akronymisierbar-Channel. Genau, ich bin
at hoodie-de.
Ich bin at kilian kao e.
Vielen lieben Dank an die Leute an der
Tontechnik dieses Mal, die
uns ermöglicht haben, unsere
wahrscheinlich qualitativ beste Folge ever
aufzunehmen. Mit Abstand.
Also vielen Dank an den Gerd, an den
Ronny, an den Karsten und an den
Alex da draußen.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurem
beginnt in 321 sei bereit bereit hat bereit ich würde mich interessieren in welcher band
gehört gespielt hat kannst du sagen viele bänden sollte gar nicht kennen soll prinzip was in berlin
tatsächlich nicht da ist die gruppe sind die kreis entstanden
ach so abgefahren das lied am fenster kennt jeder ochs
doch das war ein normaler band entstanden das ist eines meiner absoluten lieblings
wieder was hast du da gespielt das wurde für dich mit der geige sondern mit
der querflöte gespielt und die habe ich gespielt findet man die version
irgendwo noch?
Und bei Lauf und bei Schmierer bei Cine
kann er Flöte spielen können,
hat der Bassist dort die Geigen gespielt.
Deswegen war das erfolgreich.
Vorneweg hat es sich keines auch interessiert.
Ich würde gerne mal
die Version mit Querflöte hören.
Ganz ehrlich.
Da hat er einfach am Fenster mitgemacht.
Super krass.
Dieser Gerd.
Guter Typ.
Sieht auch so ein bisschen aus
wie Jethro Tull.
das wird sich aus dem ersten jetzt dr
erst keine Zitronensäure, deswegen haben sie das Brause durchgestrichen und nur noch
Pulver gemacht. Dann hat aber irgendwer von irgendwo aus irgendeiner Sofaritze Zitronensäure
gefunden und jetzt können sie wieder Brause machen. Zwischenfrage, wenn wir hier einfach
drauf loslabern, das wird schon aufgenommen, oder? Ja, das läuft schon. Ja, cool, dann
quatschen wir einfach so weiter. Die heutige Folge ist übrigens gesponsert von
Kollemate. Hier auf den Datenspuren kostet eine 0,33er Kollemate 2,50 Euro.
*laughs*